[Music]
hey everyone and welcome back to Simply
learns YouTube channel I hope you guys
are doing well in this video we'll take
you through the basics of one of the
most widely used cloud services provided
by Microsoft the Microsoft AO but before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn so let's quickly go through
the agenda for today's video in this
video first you will learn about what
Azure is and then the basics of azure
Services following that you will come
across the in-depth explanation of azure
services with proper
demonstration after that you'll learn
about Azure active directory followed by
Azure virtual machines and Azure virtual
networks then you will have a look at
Azure devops and all this will be
explained in detail with
demonstrations following that you will
see how Azure differs from other cloud
computing platforms like AWS and the
Google Cloud platform once you are done
with theoretical and practical
understanding of azure you'll explore
about all the Azure certifications that
will interest you to build your career
in future and after that you will
explore some really important Azure
interview questions and answers that
will help you make your interview
process smoother and to help you grow in
your career by the end of this video I
can assure you that all your Azure
related questions and doubts will have
been clear also you can also check out a
Azure Cloud architect course that will
help you master the Azure infrastructure
by understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azo creating
and deploying apps in Azo and securing
data with azo this Microsoft certified
Azure certification code scatters to
those who are hoping to enter the cloud
industry this program includes an Azure
exam voucher that can be availed to
appear for any one course also
candidates with one plus year of
experience are preferred for this
program so what are you waiting for
check out the link mentioned in the
description box for more details let's
take a minute to hear it out from our
Learners who have experienced massive
success in their careers with simply
loar hi my name is j Bas after
completing my btech I have started my
career with 24x7 as an interactive
social media adviser I then completed my
mtech and started working with CLE as a
configuration management database
analyst or cmdb analyst later I moved to
Val laabs as a cmdb analyst while
working with Val laabs I started
creating applications and servers and
also I ensured that the data is accurate
and up toate I wanted to grow in my
career where I can get good position and
salary hike after that I decided to take
up Microsoft a a certification course
from Simply as Microsoft is a Big Brand
I thought this course will have good
future prospects my interaction with
sales team is good because they have
told me about the course contents and
about the mobile app mobile app was very
helpful during my travel time during my
feasible time so that I can access the
CES through my mobile app people from
different parts of the world joined the
classes and we were able to chat with
them and we were able to ask the
questions to the trainer also I would
like to thank the trainer akal and I was
able to access the lab materials which
has been provided by simply learn we
have got lab sessions we got the access
to the tools where we can create the
applications after completing this
course I got a new job as a cmdb lead at
V Pro I got recognition and appreciation
from my team and also I got 30% hike I
could now lead a team in my free time I
read read books I play caram and I go
out with my team I also would like to do
development part in Microsoft Azure I
intermediate and I expert from Simply
learn many people who want to learn
Cloud Technologies I recommend you to
take simply learn course and move ahead
in the career I thank simply learn for
all the progress in my
career for this training with me I have
a experienced Azure specialist together
we'll walk you through the important
Azure Keynotes so let's start with an
exciting video on Azure crash course now
what is azure what's the big cloud
service provider all about so Azure is a
cloud computing platform provided by
Microsoft now it's basically an online
portal through which you can access and
manage resources and services now
resources and services are nothing but
you know you can store your data and you
can transform the data using services
that Microsoft provides again all you
need is the internet and being able to
connect to the Azo portal then you get
access to all of the resources and their
services in case you want to know more
about how it's different from its rival
which is AWS I suggest you click on the
top right corner and watch the AWS
versus AO video so that you can clearly
tell how both these cloud service
providers are different from each other
now here are some things that you need
to know about aor it was launched in
February 1st 2010 which is significant L
later than when AWS was launched it's
free to start and has a pay per use
model which means like I said before you
need to pay for the services you use
through Azor and one of the most
important selling points is that 80% of
Fortune 500 companies use Azure Services
which means that most of the bigger
companies of the world actually
recommend using Azure and then Azure
supports a wide variety of programming
languages the cop no JS Java and so much
more another very important important
selling point of aor is the amount of
data centers it has across the world now
it's important for a cloud service
provider to have many data centers
around the world because it means that
they can provide their services to a
wider audience now Azor has 42 which is
more than any cloud service provider has
at the moment it expects to have 12 more
in a period of time which brings its
total number of regions it covers to 54
now let's talk about Azure Services now
Azure Services have 18 categories
and more than 200 services so we clearly
can't go through all of them it has
services that cover compute a machine
learning integration management tools
identity devops web and so much more
you're going to have a hard time trying
to find a domain that asure doesn't
cover and if it doesn't cover it now you
can be certain they're working on it as
we speak so first let's start with the
compute Services first virtual machine
with this service what you're getting to
do is to create a virtual machine of
Linux or Windows operating system it's
easily configurable you can add RAM you
can decrease RAM you can add storage
remove it all of it is possible in a
matter of seconds now let's talk about
the second service cloud service now
with this you can create a application
within the cloud and all of the work
after you deploy it deploying the
application that is is taken care of by
aor which includes you know provisioning
the application load balancing ensuring
that the application is in good health
and all of the other things are handled
by aor next up let's talk about service
fabric now with service fabric the
process of developing a microservice is
greatly simplified so you might be
wondering what exactly is a microservice
now a microservice is basically an
application that consists of smaller
applications coupled together next up
functions now with functions you can
create applications in any programming
language that you want another very
important part is that you don't have to
worry about any hardware components you
don't have to worry what Ram you require
or how much storage you require all of
that is taken care of by aure all you
need is to provide the code to Azure and
it'll execute it and you don't have to
worry about anything else now let's talk
about some networking Services first up
we have Azor CDN or the content delivery
Network now the Azor CDN service is
basically for delivering web content to
users now this content is of high
bandwidth and can be transferred or can
be delivered to any person across the
world now these are actually a network
of servers that are placed in strategic
positions across the world so that the
customers can obtain this data as fast
as possible next up we have expess R now
with this you can actually connect your
on promise Network onto the Microsoft
cloud or any of the services that you
want through a private connection so the
only communication that happens is
between your on promise Network and the
service that you want then you have
virtual Network now with virtual Network
you can have any of the Azure Services
communicate with each other in a secure
manner in a private manner next we have
Azure DNS so Azure DNS is a hosting
service which allows you to host their
DNS or domain name system domains in
Azure so you can host your application
using a your DNS now for the storage
Services first up we have dis storage
with dis storage you're given a
costeffective option of choosing HDD or
solid state drives to go along with your
virtual machines based on your
requirements then you have blob storage
now this is actually optimized to ensure
that they can store massive amounts of
unstructured data which can include Text
data or even binary data next you have
file storage which is a managed file
storage and can be accessible via the
SMB protocol or the server message block
protocol and finally you have q storage
now with Q storage you can provide
durable message queuing for an extremely
large workload and the most important
part is that that this can be accessed
from anywhere in the world now let's
talk about how aor can be used firstly
for application development it could be
any application mostly web applications
then you can test the application see
how well it works you can host the
application on the internet you can
create virtual machines like I mentioned
before with the service you can create
these virtual Machines of any size or
Ram that you want you can integrate In
Sync features you can collect and store
metrices for example how the data Works
how the current dat data is how you can
improve upon it all of that is possible
with these services and you have virtual
hard drives which is an extension of the
virtual machines where these services
are able to provide you a large amount
of storage where data can be stored you
can also check out Azure Cloud architect
codes that will help you master the
Azure infrastructure by understanding
Azure Cloud architect Technology
Solutions implementing workloads and
Security in Azure creating and deploying
apps in Azure and securing data in Azure
link is in the description also do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon for more amazing and
interesting content so the wide variety
of services available on Azure includes
artificial intelligence plus machine
learning plus analytic services to get
an or to give us a good visual of how
the data or how the application is
performing or the type of the category
of data stored and to read from from the
logs and variety of compute Services
different VMS with different size and
different operating systems different
containers available different type of
databases available a lot of developer
tools that are available for us and
identity service to manage our users in
the Azure cloud and those users can be
integrated or Federated with let's say
Google Facebook you know LinkedIn so
they they are some external Federation
Services they can be used to integrate
with our identity system iots iot
Services iot tools and Technologies
available and management tools to manage
the users you know creating identities
one and then managing them on top of it
is a totally different thing and we have
tools Technologies to manage the users
cool services for data migration data
migration is now made Made Simple tools
and Technologies available for mobile
application development and I can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking Services I can Implement my
own security both Azure provider and
third party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in specific let's take
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new application or
deploying existing ones the Azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux v
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate rvms to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or in on premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides some of the
services the compute domain provides are
virtual machines and this Azure virtual
machines gives us the ability to develop
and manage a virtual computer
environment or a virtualized environment
inside azures Cloud environment that to
in a virtual private Network now we will
talk about virtual private Network at a
later point but as of now just know that
there are a lot of services available in
Azure compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of uh computer options
for example you know we have an option
to choose the operating system we have
the option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on premises and in
the Cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
software attached uh to it or do we want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from Azure Marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these compute
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pay for what we use model
meaning there is no upfront cost we use
the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal long-term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a payper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
payper minute billing model at no point
we will be overpaying for any of the
services that's that's attractive isn't
it now let's talk about batch service
now batch service is always independent
regardless of whether you choose windows
or Linux it's going to run fairly well
and with bat servers we can take
advantage of the environment's unique
features and not only that in short the
batch service helps us to manage the
whole batch environment and also it
helps to schedule the jobs now this
Azure batch service is actually runs on
a large scale parallel and high
performance Computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in Azure
and when we run batch services this
Azure batch creates a pool of computer
nodes and uh installs the needed
applications that we want to run and
then it's schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually schedules the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
bat service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and uh the networking
services that we would be using for this
batch service let's summarize this batch
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in cues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this batch service
helps us to manage uh the application
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what's service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and uh life cycle
management to Applications that are
composed of microservices no
infrastructure management at all and
with service fabric we can easily scale
the application to tens or hundreds or
even to thousands of machines here
machines represent containers as next
thing in comput domain let's talk about
virtual machine scale set now this
virtual machine scale set it lets us to
create a group of identical load
balanced VMS I just want to mention it
again it helps us to manage group
identical and load balanced VMS the
number of instances or the number of VM
instances in an in a scale set can
increase or decrease in response to uh
the demand or in response to a schedule
that we Define you know the resources
needed on a Monday morning is not the
same as that would be required on a
Saturday or a Sunday morning all right
and even within the day the resources
that would be needed the beginning of
the business hour is not the resources
that would be needed at noon or you know
after 8: or 9 in the evening so the
demands could actually vary in the
environment and this skill set helps us
to take care of the weing demand or take
care of the uh different infrastructure
requirement at a different schedules
throughout the day throughout the week
throughout the month or could be
throughout the year as well the scal set
also allows us to provide High
availability to our applications and it
helps us to uh centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine scill set just like I said this
virtual machine scale set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes uh the requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machines with virtual
machine scale set we can centrally
manage and configure and update a big
group of VMS and it's a great use case
when it comes to Big Data or container
workloads as next thing in compute
domain uh let's talk about cloud
services now this Azure cloud service is
actually a platform as a service and
it's very friendly in fact it is
designed for applications that support
scalability or an application that
requires scalability or reliability and
and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so Azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like VMS we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
look at the responsibility the
responsibility for us in VM is that we
manage everything end to end like uh you
know deploying new patchers picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
I mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform I mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by Azure
like know deploying new versions of the
operating system it's all handled by the
Azure so we deploy the application and
we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
Azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
uh where we can uh write uh the uh
application code and we don't have to
worry about Hardware simply hand over
the code and cloud service takes care of
it so no worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something uh crashes how do I
update the infrastructure how do I
manage uh the maintenance or the
downtime in the underlying
infrastructure all that is handled by
Azure it also provides an good testing
environment for us you know we can
simply run the code
test it before it's actually released to
the production I want to expand a bit on
these testing applications so this aure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the the staging
environment into the production
environment and the old production
environment will now become the new
staging environment where we can uh add
more to it and then swap it back at a
later point so it it kind of gives us an
swappable environment for testing our
applications and not only that it gives
us Health monitoring alerts it helps us
to monitor the health and availability
of our application there is a dashboard
we can benefit from uh when we use Azure
cloud services and that shows the key
statistics all in one place and we can
also set up realtime alerts to one when
a service availability or a certain
metrics that we are concerned about
degrades as next thing in compute domain
let's talk about functions now functions
are serverless Computing now many time
if you heard about Azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless uh
Computing or azure functions which is a
serverless Computing service hosted on
Microsoft Azure the main motive of uh a
function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running uh that code and
the best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what does Azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless uh
simple functions with the programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is c f nodejs Java and PHP so here we
really don't have to worry about
provisioning or uh maintaining servers
if a code requires more resource yes
Azure functions handles or it provides
the additional resources needed by the
code and the best part is we only pay
for the amount of time the functions are
running not the resources but the amount
of time the function is running as next
thing and moving to the new domain let's
talk about the container domain in Azure
now the container domain or the
container service it allows us to
quickly deploy a production ready
kubernetes or a Docker swamp cluster now
what's a container a container is a
standard unit of software that packages
of code and all its dependencies so the
applications run quickly and reliably
from one Computing environment to
another it could be testing uh to
staging to developing development
environment to staging to production or
from one production to another
production or on premises to cloud or
one Cloud to another Cloud vice versa
now imagine we had an option not to
worry about the VM and just focus on the
application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
lawning the new tools required to manage
the VMS or even the deployment and our
applications that we create they run in
a container running in a container is
what helps us to achieve all these not
being able to manage or not needing to
manage the virtual machines so these
containers uh they can be deployed into
the cloud using a single command if
you're using a command line interface
and a couple of button clicks if we are
using the Azure portal and these
containers are kept lightweight but they
are equally secure as virtual machines
let's talk about container service as
next thing uh the container service or
sometimes called as Azure kubernetes
service it helps us to manage the
containers containers is one thing and a
service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it it actually provides a
way uh to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configure to run containerized
applications on top of them and
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provision we can actually manage them by
using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS very it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and ACS also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell man managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that uh a
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive
environment this AKs helps us to
simplify that environment all right as
next thing in container domain let's
talk about container registry we spoke
about registry a little bit when we
spoke about Docker images so container
registry is a single place where we can
store our images which are Docker images
when we use when we use containers it's
it's doer images that we use for our
image purposes so these container images
are a central registry that can be used
to ease container development by easing
the storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like U Docker swarm or the images
used in Docker swarm are in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now this Geor replication it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geor replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global uh replication
Center we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images would have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then provisioning of the applications
Global wide and this replication also
helps us to helps us Network latency
because you know anytime an application
needs to deploy it does not have to rely
on a single source which which can be
reached only through high latency
Network because we have Global
replications around the world anytime
the application wants to check back it
would check back uh the application
which is in a very nearby location for
the application itself Global
replication means that we are managing
it as a single entity that's being
replicated across the multiple regions
in the globe as next thing in know
learning let's talk about um Azure
databases now this Azure databases are
uh uh rational in fact they have uh many
flavors in them uh we're going to look
at uh different flavors SQL nosql cache
type of database that Azure offers so
we're going to learn one at a time or
we're going to learn one by one so this
Azure SQL database is a rational
database in fact it's a rational
database as a service it's managed by
Azure we don't get to do a lot of
management in it so it's a rational
database as a service uh based on
Microsoft the SQL Server database engine
and this database is a a high
performance database it very reliable
and uh it's very secure as well and this
High reliability high performance and
for this high security we really don't
have to do anything it comes along with
it and uh it's managed by Azure and
there are two things that I definitely
need to mention about Azure SQL database
that is it's an intelligent service
number one it's fully managed by azure
and it also has this one good thing
which is it has built-in intelligence
that learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance and reliability and
data protection of the application
that's something that's not found in uh
many of the other Cloud providers that
I'm aware of so I thought I'll mention
it so it uses built-in intelligence to
learn about um the user's database
patterns and helps improve performance
and protection and migration
or importing data is very easy when it
comes to Azure SQL database so it can be
readily or immediately used for analytic
reporting and uh intelligent
applications in Azure as next thing
let's talk about Azure cosmod DB now
Azure cosmod DB is a database service
that is for no SQL type and uh it's it's
created to provide low latency and uh an
application that scales dynamically or
that scales rapidly
now this Azure cosmod DB is an a
globally distributed service and it's a
multimodel database this can be
provisioned in a click off a button
that's all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure Cosmo DB in the
Azure it helps with scaling the database
you know we can elastically and
independently scale throughput and
storage across this database and in any
of the Azure geographic regions it
provid provides a good throughput it
provides good latency it provides good
availability and um it provides or Azure
promises a a comprehensive SLA that uh
no other database can offer that's the
best part about cosmod DB so this cosmod
DB was built with global distribution in
mind and it's built uh with a horizontal
scale in mind and all this we can use by
only paying for what we have used and
remember the difference between Azure
cosmod DB and the SQL database is that
Azure cosmod DB supports no SQL whereas
SQL doesn't all right few other things
about Azure cosmod DB is it allows users
to use key value graph a column family
and document data it also gives users a
number of AP options like SQL JavaScript
mongodb and and few others that you
might want to check at the document at
at the time of reading and the best part
here is that all that we mentioned we
get to use only by paying for the amount
of storage and throughput that are
required and the storage and the
throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of that R all
right let's talk about um redis cache
discussion about Azure database won't be
complete without we talking about redis
cache now reddis cache is a secure data
cache it's also called it's also
sometimes called as messaging broker
that provides high throughput and low
latency access to data for the
applications now redis cache is based on
an a popular open-source caching product
which is redis sometimes called as redis
cache now what's the use case it's
typically used to Cache to improve the
performance and scalability of a system
that rely heavily on backend data stores
now performance when we use redis cach
is improved by temporarily copying the
frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cach this
fast storage is is located in memory
with redis cache instead of being loaded
from the actual disk in the database
itself now this redis Cache can also be
used as an in-memory data structure
store not only that it can be used as an
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
uh use cases for this redis cache and by
using redis cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
high throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this R cach is actually backed by redu
server and it supports u a string hashes
linked list and various other data
structures now let's talk about security
and identity Services now identity
management in specific is a process of
authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
and not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's an principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the speciality about uh this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like like
identity management can provide
multiactor authentication it can provide
access policies based on condition
permit or deny based on condition it can
also monitor suspicious activity and not
only that it can also report it it can
also help generate alerts for potential
security issues and in a way to mitigate
it can send us an alert so we can get
involved and prevent an security
accident from happening so let's talk
more about identity management so some
of the services under security and
identity management are Azure security
center now this Azure security Center
provides Security Management and threat
protection across the workloads in both
cloud and in the hybrid environment it
helps control user access and
application control to stop any
malicious activity if present it helps
us to find and fix what vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
deduct attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environment so
you don't have to have one policy for on
premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for on
premises and the cloud the next servers
in security and identity would be keyal
now a keyal is a service or a feature
that helps safegard the cryptographic
keys and any other Secrets used by the
cloud applications and the services in
other words this Azure keywall is a tool
for securely storing and accessing the
secrets of the environment I mean the
secret Keys now a secret is anything
that you really want to have a very
tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyal is now keyal is used
in Secrets management it's helped in
securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management you know it really helps
in creating and controlling the
encryption keys that we would use to
encrypt data it helps in certificate m
management talking about certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy public and
private SSL TLS certificates in Azure
and a lot more so in a nutshell this
keywall it provides users the ability to
provision new walls and keys in just a
matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their keys secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities what what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloudbased active directory and identity
management service now Azure active
directory combines and it's actually a
combination of the core directory
Services Plus application access
management plus identity protection and
one good thing about this Azure in fact
there are a lot of good things but
especially when you're running hybrid
environments you might wonder well how
this Azure active directory is going to
behave now this Azure active directory
is built to work on on premises and
Cloud enironment as well not only that
it also works seamlessly with mobile
applications as well so in an nutshell
this Azure active directory it acts as
an central point of identity and access
management for our Cloud environment it
also provides good Security Solutions
that protect against unauthorized access
of our app and the data now that we have
discussed about security and identity
let's talk about the management tools
that Azure has to offer Azure provides
builtin management and account
governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build uh
disaster recoveries it also helps in
applying policies and conditions to
automate our environment we use Azure
management tools and it's also used in
cost control methods so this Azure
management plays a wide role across the
Azure services and in the management
tools first comes the Azure advisor now
this Azure advisor it acts as a guide to
educate our about Azure best practices
it throws recommendations that we can
select on the basis of the category of
servers and it also provides the impact
it can have or the impact that would
happen in our environment if we follow
the recommendations given and
recommendations are first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws uh the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis basis of the configuration on
the basis of our usage patterns and
these recommendations are not hard it's
not like something that it recommends
and then just leaves us hanging there
these recommendations provided are very
easy to follow very easy to implement
and see results you can think of azure
advisor as an very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of anal izes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps and improve the
performance security High availability
of our environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure usage and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment next in the list would be
Network Watcher now this network Watcher
helps users identify and gain insights
in the overall Network performance and
the health of the overall environment
now these Azure Watchers provides enough
tools to monitor to diagnose to view the
metrics and to enable or disable logs
which means you know generate and
collect collect the logs for resources
in the Azure virtual Network so with
network Watcher can monitor and diagnose
issues in networking without even
logging into the virtual machines with
just the logs which are real time we can
actually come to a conclusion what could
be wrong in a certain resource in a VM
or in a database you know but just
looking at the logs and not only that
it's used for analytic or to gain some
intelligence of what's happening in our
Network we can gain lot of insight to
the current Network traffic pattern
using the security group flow logs that
this network Watcher offers it also
helps in investigating VPN connectivity
issues using detailed logs now you might
or might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties you other person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs in our end stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the list
would be Microsoft Azure portal now this
Microsoft Azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building building
managing and monitoring the web
applications that we build now this
portal can be used to organize our
environment or the appearance of the
environment or the visual of the
environment based on our workstyle and
using Azure portal users can control who
gets to manage or access the resources
all from the Azure portal and this AO
portal gives a very good visibility on
the spin that happen on each Source
right and if we can customize it we can
also identify spend based on team spends
based on days spends based on Department
stuff like that so it kind of gives us a
good visual of where the money is
spending or where is the bill consumed
within the Azure environment next in the
list would be Azure resource manager now
Azure resource manager enables us to
manage the usage of the application
resources now we use resource manager to
deploy Monitor and manage solution
resources as a group as if it's one
single entity now the infrastructure of
our application is typically made of
various components which includes
virtual machine storage virtual Network
web app database servers some other
thirdparty services that we might use in
our environment and they are by nature
separate services but with Azure
resource manager we don't see them as
different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure resource
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that there is sources that we
provision or deploy at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources lot
better resource Group also is used to
control who can access the resources
within the users organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across hybrid environments it provides a
cloud-based Automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non- aure environments as
well which is on premises so some of the
automation we could do is process
automation update management aut
automation configuration features
automation stuff like that and this
Azure automation provides complete
control during the deployment operation
and also during the decommissioning of
the workloads and resources with
automation we can actually automate uh
time consuming or mundane or any task
that's error prone because of uh human
errors those things can be automated so
irrespective of how many times you run
it it it's going to run the same way and
that really helps in reducing the
overall time and also the overhead cost
because a lot of the things are
automated which means it's human error
free which means the application is not
going to break and keep running for a
longer time with automation we can
actually build a good inventory of
operating system resources and
configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the is let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure then there
are variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps an accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as load times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application let's
expand on this the content delivery
network is actually a distributed
network of servers that can efficiently
deliver web content to users now cdns
we're going to use the word CDN here CDN
store cached content on global Edge
servers also called as uh pops point of
presence locations that are very close
to the end users so the latency is
minimized it's like taking a copy of the
data or taking a multiple copy of the
data and storing it in different parts
of the world and whoever is requesting
it the data gets delivered to them from
a server which is very locally to them
so this CDN offers developers a global
solution for rapidly delivering high
bandwidth content to users by caching
the content in a strategically placed
location which is very near to them so
these content delivery networks it
really helps in handling that one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very efficiently and we can
also run analytic against the logs that
gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the resource first
and then you only pay for what you have
used the next one in networking would be
express route now express route is
actually a circuit or a link that
provides an a direct private connection
to Azure and because it's direct it
gives low latency link to Azure it gives
good speed and reliability for for the
Azure data transfer it could be on
premises to Azure so it gives very good
speed it gives increased reliability and
low latency for that connection let's
expand on this a bit now this express
route is an service that actually
provides an private connection between
Microsoft Data Center and infrastructure
in our premises or in a different
cocation facility that we might have now
these Express routes do not go over the
public internet and because they don't
go over the public internet they offer
high security reliability and speed and
low latency compared to the connections
which are in the internet because it's
fast because it's reliable because it it
has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising privacy or the performance
now these virtual private Cloud these
Express routes can be used for taking
backups if Zoom a backup going through
the internet that would be a nightmare
if if you use express route for backups
that's going to be fast and imagine
recovering a data through the internet
from the cloud through the internet to
the on premises in a time of disaster
that would be the worst nightmare so
these Express routes can be used not
only to backup but also to recover the
data because it provides good speed low
latency recovering the data is going to
be lot sooner the next product or
service we're going to discuss in
networking is azure DNS
now Azure DNS allows us to host domain
name in Azure and these domain names
come with an exceptional performance and
availability now Azure DNS is used to
set up and manage a DNS zones and
records for our domain name in the cloud
now this Azure DNS is a service for DNS
just like the name says and it provides
name resolution by using azures
infrastructure and uh by using this
domain we can actually manage the DNS
ourselves through the Azure portal with
the same credential imagine having a DNS
provider which does not even belong in
our it imagine that environment you know
we would have a separate portal to
manage the DNS environment now those are
gone and now we can actually manage the
DNS in the very same Azure portal where
we use the rest of the other services
and this Azure DNS where much integrates
with other DNS service providers it uses
a Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other uh
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resync
let's say a server fails it kind of
helps resyncing with the rest of the
servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time right next in
the list in networking Services is
virtual Network I'm sure this is going
to be very interesting and I'm sure
you're going to like it so this
networking or virtual networking in
azzure it actually allows us to set up
our own private cloud in the public
Cloud it gives us an isolated and highly
secure environment for our application
let's expand on this and this Azure
virtual Network helps us to provision
Azure virtual machines and uh it helps
us to securely communicate with other on
premises and internet networks it also
helps in controlling the traffic that
flows through or Flows In and Out of
This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as vet is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a vnet that is separate
from another customer's vets that way we
have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision vpns in the cloud so we can
connect the cloud and the on premises
infrastructure and lot more especially
in a environment where we have hybrid
environment surely we will be using
virtual Network because that's going to
require a VPN for secure data transfer
in and out of the cloud and in and out
of the on premises environment all right
right so it kind of gives us an boundary
for all the resources so all the traffic
between the Azure resources they kind of
logically stay in between or logically
stay within the Azure virtual Network
and here we can design the network it's
given over to us you know you can pick
the IP you can pick the routing you can
pick the subnet and a lot of freedom is
given or I would say a lot of control on
how the netor work is designed it's not
like something that's already cooked and
we only get to use it no we can actually
build the network from the scratch we
can pick the IP address that we like we
can pick you know which subnet needs to
communicate with the other subnet stuff
like that and like I said if you are
using hybrid environment you definitely
would be requiring a virtual Network
because it helps connect the on premises
and the cloud in a secure fashion using
VPN the last product we're going to
discuss in networking is a load balancer
this load balancer actually provides
application a good availability and a
good Network performance so how does it
work it actually works by load balancing
the traffic to and from the virtual
machine and the cloud resources not only
that it also load balances between cloud
and cross premises virtual networks with
azured load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balances supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the backend pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now Azure storage in general is
a a Microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they C different needs
and the storage products include Azure
blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes um Azure data Lake
it includes Azure files as you see it it
includes Azure cues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
cost off storage to nearly 60% of how
much you would be actually spending
without using it so Azure simple storage
or store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around a hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with the Azure especially when it
comes to storage a lot of the things
that we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason Reon why it got store simple
is really because it uses store simple
8000 series devices which are used in
Azure Data Center and this uh store
simple or simple storage it comes along
with storage steering to manage uh the
stored data cross the various storage
media so the current the very current
data is actually stored in on premises
on solid state drives and data that is
used less frequently is stored in uh
hdds or hard dis drives and the data
that requires archived or that needs to
be archived very old data let's say less
frequently used data candidate for
archived they are actually pushed uh to
the cloud so you see how this storage
steering automatically happens in store
simple and one another cool feature of
store simple is that it enables us to
create an on demand and scheduled
backups of data and and then store the
data locally or in the cloud and these
backups are actually taken in the the
form of incremental snapshot which means
that they can be created and restored
quickly it's not a complete backup it's
an incremental backup and these Cloud
snapshots they can be critically
important when there is a disaster and
when there is a disaster recovery
scenario because these snapshots can be
called in and they can be put on storage
systems and then they become the actual
data so recovering is faster if you have
proper scheduled backups or if you have
frequent backups and this storage simple
it really helps in easing our backup
mechanism which means it kind of easers
our Disaster Recovery steps or
procedures as well so this store simple
it can be used to automate data
management data migration data movement
data teering across the Enterprise both
in cloud and on premises it actually
improves the compliance and accelerates
the disaster recovery for our
environment and if there is one thing
that's increasing every every new day in
our environment that would be storage
and this store simple addresses that
need and we really don't have to
pre-plan or or think in deep or having a
proper storage because now we have a
simple storage available in the cloud
and moreover it's on a pay as you go
type so not much pre-planning on storage
is needed yes there would be a need but
not as much as I would without the cloud
or without the simple storage and the
next servers under storage that we would
like to discuss is the data Lake store
this data Lake store or storage it's a
cost effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and and of any injection speed and it
kind of collects them in one single
space or in one single place for
operational efficiency I mean
operational efficiency and for analytic
purpose Hado in Azure is very dependent
on this data Lake storage and this uh
data Lake store is designed with
performance for analytics in mind so
anytime you think of or anytime you're
using analytic in the cloud or anytime
you're using Hado in the cloud in Azure
we are definitely using or we will be to
the most part or the normal procedure or
the Right Storage to pick would be data
Le store in Azure it's designed with
security in mind so anytime we use Azure
storage we can be rest assured that we
are using storage from within a data
center which has or which was built with
security in mind so this data store also
uses Azure blob storage behind the
scenes for global scale durability and
for performance let's talk about blob
storage now blob storage provides large
amount of storage and scalability now
this blob storage is the object storage
solution for Azure Cloud let's expand a
bit on blob storage Azure blob storage
is Microsoft offering for object storage
now this blob storage is optimized for
storing massive amount of unstructured
data which could be text or bin data
it's designed and it's optimized for
Rapid reads if I explained to you on
what scenarios we would be using blob
storage that might help you get a good
understanding of what blob storage is so
it's helped or it's designed as of now
it's being used in many it environments
to serve images or documents directly to
the browser it helps in storing files
for distributed access a lot of Fetchers
can fetch data from Azure blob storage
and it currently helping users stream
video and audio it's currently being
used for writing log files it's
currently being used to store data as
backup and restore at a later point in
times of Disaster Recovery it also is
used as an archiving storage in a lot of
cloud it environments it's widely used
in storing analytic data not only
storing but also running analytic query
against the data stored in it so that's
a wide use case for blob storage not
only that in addition to all that we
mentioned uh it also supports versioning
so anytime somebody updates and data a
new version gets created which means at
any point I can roll back as in when
needed and it provides a lot of
flexibility on optimizing the users's
storage need it also supports uh tearing
of the data So based on need when I
actually explore I would find a lot of
options I can pick from that uh you know
suits to my unique storage environment
or unique storage need and like I said
it stores unstructured data and this
unstructured data is available for
customers through rest based object
storage environment the next product and
storage service would be Q storage now Q
storage provides durable cues for large
volume cloud services it's a very simple
and a cost effective durable messaging
queue for large workloads let's expand
this Q storage for a moment now this Q
storage is a service for storing large
amount of messages that can be accessed
from anywhere in the world through HTTP
and https calls a single CU or a single
CU message can be up to like 24 KB in
size and a single Q can contain millions
of such 24 KB in size messages and how
much can it hold it can hold up to the
total capacity of the storage account
itself so that's kind of easy to
translate How much would it hold and
this Azure Q storage it provides an
messaging solution between applications
and components in the cloud what does it
help it helps in designing an
application for scale it helps in
decoupling the application so you know
it's not very dependent or sometimes
it's not at all dependent on the other
application because now we have a queue
in between which kind kind of translates
or which kind of connects or which kind
of decouples both the environment now we
have a queue in between both the
environment can scale up or scale down
independently the next in the storage
service would be file storage let's talk
about file storage now these Azure files
provide secure simple and managed Cloud
file shares now with file share in the
cloud it actually extends the user
servers on premises performance and
capacity
and lot of familiar tools for the cloud
file share management can be used along
with the file storage that we're talking
about so let's expand a bit on file
storage now this Azure files or Azure
file storage offers a fully managed file
shares in the cloud that can be accessed
via the uh SMB protocol server message
block protocol now this Azure file
shares can be mounted concurrently by
cloud or in on premises deployments a
lot of operating systems are compatible
with it windows are compatible Linux is
compatible Mac OS is compatible in in
addition to all these being able to run
on on premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cache for
caching uh the data and keeping it
locally so it's immediately available
when needed so that's some additional
feature I would say that's some advanced
feature that it offers compared to the
other file shares available in the
market let's talk about table storage
let's talk about table storage now table
storage is a nosql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with a
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so any any time you want
to pick a schema less a no SQL type
table storage is the one we'll end up
picking it provides an key pair
attribute storage with a schema less
design this table storage is very fast
and very cost effective for many of the
applications and for the same amount of
uh data it's a lot cheaper when you
compare it with the traditional SQL data
or data storage so some of the things
that we can store in the table store
storage are of course they're going to
be flexible data sheets uh such as user
data for web application address books
device information and other types of
metadata for our service requirements
and it can have any number of tables up
to the capacity limit of the storage
account now this is not possible with
SQL this is only possible with no SQL
especially with table storage in Azure
explanation of storage really concluded
the length and bread of the explanation
this CEO was giving his uh IT personnel
but this it personel is not done with it
yet he still has a question even after
this lengthy discussion and his question
was well there are a lot of other Cloud
providers available what made you
specifically choose Azure I mean from
the kind of question that he asked we
can say that he is very curious and uh
he definitely had asked an very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the uh
other capabilities of azure or how it
kind of outruns the rest of the cloud
providers so he started or he again
started his discussion but from
different angle now so he started to
explain what are the capabilities or how
Azure is better than uh the competitor
so he started with explaining the
platform as a service capabilities and
I'm going to tell you what the CEO told
his ID person so this platform as a
service or in platform as a service the
infrastructure management is completely
taken care by uh Microsoft allowing
users to focus completely on the
innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and u Azure especially is U net friendly
Azure supports the net programming
language and um it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and new applications deployed using
net programming framework so if your
application isnet most of the time you
would end up picking Azure I mean if you
try to compare most of the time you
would end up picking Azure as your cloud
service provider and the security
offerings that Azure offers is it's
designed based on the security
development uh life cycle which is an
industry leading Assurance process when
we buy services from Azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like I mentioned many times in the past
and I would like to mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other Cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the uh documentation it's picture
rich and the documentations are neat and
clear would really it would encourage
you to to learn more it would encourage
you to think and imagine and try easily
get a grasp of how Services works so it
has a very gentle learning curve Azure
allows the utilization of technologies
that several business have used for
years so there is a big history behind
it it has a very gentle learning curve
the the certifications the
documentations the stage-by-stage
certification levels it's all very
gentle learning curve which is generally
missing in other cloud service providers
now this would really impress the CTO or
or people working in finance and
budgeting if an organization is already
using Microsoft software they can
definitely go and Avail or be bold and
ask for a discount that can reduce the
overall Azure spending in other words
overall pricing of the Azure so that's
what helped or they are the information
that helped the CEO pick Azure as his
cloud service provider and then the CEO
goes on and talks about the different
companies that are currently using Azure
and they are definitely using Azure for
a reason like Pixar Boeing Samsung
EasyJet Xerox BMW 3M they are major
multinational multi-billion companies
they rely run operate their it in Azure
and this CEO has a thought that his it
person is still not very convinced
unless and until he shows him a visual
of how easy things are in Azure so he
goes on and explains about a practical
application of azure which is what
exactly I'm going to show you as well
all right a quick project on building an
Azure app using or building a net
application in Azure web app and making
it connect to an SQL database will
solidify all the knowledge that we have
gained so far so this is what we're
going to do I have an Azure account open
as you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're going to do so we're
going to create an application like this
which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application
we're just going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
thing is to create and Resource Group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it Azure simply Lear all right and
it's going to be a free trial and the
location pick one that's nearest to you
or you know wherever you want to launch
your application now for this use case
I'm going to pick Central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and an a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this U example so
let's create an web app uh give it a
quick name let's call it uh Azure uh
simply learn the subscription is free
trial and I'm going to use my existing
Resource Group a resource Group that we
created some time back it's going to run
out of Windows and we're going to
publish the code all set we can create
it all right while this is running uh
let me create my uh
database right SQL database create a
database give it a name let's call it
Azure simply learn
DB put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some uh settings like the name
of the server and the admin login the
password that goes along and in which
location this is going to be created the
server name is going to be aure simply
learn DB that's the server name and the
admin login can be
what can be the admin login name let's
see so let's call it simply laar that's
my admin login name and let me pick a
password click on create so what have we
done so far we have created an web app
and we have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now as you
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created you know it's
still being created all right in the
meantime I have my application right
here that's running out of uh or that's
in Visual Studio as of now right so once
the infrastructure is set and ready in
the Azure console uh we're going to go
back to visual studio a feed these
inputs in the visual studio so the code
knows what the database is the the
credentials to log into the database
stuff like that so we're going to feed
those information in Visual Studio by
that we're actually feeding it into the
application and then we're going to run
it from there deploying these
application takes uh quite a while we
really got to be patient all right now
we have all the resources that we need
for the application to run here is my uh
database and here is my app service
there's one more thing we need to do
that is um create an firewall exception
rule so one more thing needed is to
create an firewall exception uh rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the uh uh database right so
let's add an exception rule by simply
adding the client IP it's going to pick
my IP the IP of laptop I'm using as a
now and it's going to create an
exception to access the database so
that's done now we can go back to our
Visual Studio I already have a couple of
um apps running or couple of uh
configurations pushed from Visual Studio
I'm going to clean that up if you're
doing it for the first time you you may
not uh need to do
this all right so let's start from the
scratch this is we very similar to how
you would be doing in your environment
all right so we're going to uh select an
existing Azure app service now before
that I have logged in as you can see I
have logged in with my credential so
it's going to pull few things
automatically from my Azure account so
in this case I'm going to use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on
publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while
back
all right we have clicked on Save and
it's running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an URL
now initially the URL is uh not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database so that
would be the next
thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my uh web app as
of now it's going to throw an error like
you see it's throwing an error that's
because we haven't mapped the app and
the DB together so let's do
that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server Explorer uh this is where uh
we're going to see our U uh databases
that we have created now let's quickly
verify that go back to uh the resource
Group right appropriate Resource Group
which is right here and uh here I have
my uh database Azure simply learn
database
all right it has some issues connecting
uh to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix
it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application all right
so let's go to the solution Explorer
click on
publish and a page like this get shown
and from here we can go to
configure here is our web app all right
with all its uh credentials let's
validate the connection number one all
right and then click on
next this is my DB connection string all
right which the app is going to use to
connect to my DB now if you recall R DB
was U Azure simply learn DB and that's
not being shown here so let's fix
that right so let's fix
that click on configure and here uh
let's put our DB servers uh URL now
before that let's change this to SQL
Server all right and then in here I'll
put the DB's URL so go back to Azure
here is my DB or server's name put that
here right the username to connect to
the server that's right here put that in
and the
password
to connect to the server let's put that
in all right it's trying to connect to
our Azure portal or the Azure
infrastructure and here is my database
if you recall it's Azure uh sldb that's
the name of the database Let's test the
connection connection is good click on
okay so now it's showing up correctly
Azure simply learn DB that's the name of
uh the database that we created now it's
configured all right let's modify the
data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is azure simply learn
DB and then uh it's going to be SQL
Server that's the data source
the username is simply learn and the
password is what we have given in the
beginning all right let's validate the
connection it's good click
okay now we're all set and ready to
publish our application again now the
application knows how to connect uh to
the database we have educated it with
with the um the correct connection
strings the DNS name the username and
the password for the application to
connect to the
database so visual studi is building
this project and once it is up and
running will be prompted with an URL uh
to connect and anytime we put or we give
inputs to the URL that's going to
receive the input and save it in the
database
all right so here is my uh to-do list
app and I can start uh creating to-do
list for myself all right so I have
items already listed um I can create an
entry and these entries get stored in
the U in the database I can create
another entry and I'll take the dog for
a walk that's going to get stored I can
create another entry uh book tickets for
uh scientific uh
exhibition and that's going to receive
and put that in the database and that
concludes our session so through this
session we saw how I can use Azure
services to create web app and connect
that to the DB instance and how those
two Services which are decoupled by
default which are separate by default
how I can you know use the connection
strings to make connection between the
app server and the database and be able
to create an working app you can also
check out a Azure Cloud architect course
that will help you master the Azure
infrastructure by understanding Azure
Cloud architect Technology Solutions
implementing workloads and Security in
azure creating and deploying apps in
azzure and securing data in Azure link
is in the description also do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon for more amazing and interesting
content you can also check out a Azure
Cloud architect course that will help
you master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azo so what
are you waiting for check out the link
mentioned in the description box for for
more details what is aor active
directory now here we're in a situation
where we have two colleagues having a
conversation with each other so one of
them complains that he's finding a hard
time managing multiple user logins at
the same time his friend suggests that
he has a solution that the company start
using Azor active directory he says that
with Azor ad they'll be able to handle
multiple user logins without any issue
so just like the question in all our
minds the friend asks how is a your
active directory going to help us so to
help you understand let's think about a
scenario you're an employee working for
an organization and you want to use a
particular service in this case SQL
database so you're assigned a set of
username and password then you want to
use another service a machine learning
service again you're assigned a
different username and password and
likewise for any number of services that
you want to use so for every service
that you're going to choose you need to
be assigned a new username and password
but this becomes a huge issue for the
administrator as they have to handle a
lot large number of username and
passwords now if you think about a large
organization where there's more than
thousand people working you can
understand how much of a hassle it's
going to be for the administrator at the
same time it's also a really difficult
thing for you to remember that many
numbers of username and passwords it's
difficult on the user as well and that's
where aure active directory helps now
here's a scenario where we are applying
aure active directory now you're an
employee you want to use a particular
service and you assigned a single
username and password and with this
username and password you can access all
the services that you want so there's
only one set of username and passwords
that you need to remember you can use
any of the services that you want as
long as the administrator has given you
access to it so what is azure active
directory now Azure active directory is
a service that falls under the identity
domain it allows multiple users and is a
cloud-based directory and identity
management service now here's an ideal
scenario you're joining an office newly
the admin helps you sign up to whatever
Services you want and you can access
these Services anywhere over the cloud
so now let's talk about something
different Windows ad and Azure ad now
Windows ad was the previous version of
azure ad so now we'll talk about why we
needed to change from Windows Active
Directory to Azure active directory so
what is Windows Active Directory now
it's an OS directory service which
allows you to work with multiple systems
multiple network resources in a unified
manner now the biggest draw when it came
to Windows ad was that it had many
layers now different layers that did
different bits of work so now let's talk
about each of these layers the first
layer is adds or the windows active
directory domain Services now each layer
as I said before has a different role to
perform adds allows admin to manage
information relating to user logins and
other details like when they signed up
how much they using and things like that
the next layer is ADLs or the Azure data
leag store storage services this layer
is for allowing you to store any amounts
of data of any type or size then you
have the adfs or the active directory
Federation Services where you're given a
single option for sign up with which you
get access to all systems and
applications then we have the fourth
layer the adcs or the active directory
and certification services this enables
administrators to customize services and
then be able to manage and issue public
certificates and the final layer is adms
or the active directory Rights
Management Service and this is used for
data protection now here's where a your
active directory changeed the whole game
this means that there's a large number
of layers that administrators need to
take care of now how about there was a
solution for this and as your ad is that
solution Azure active directory
integrates all these five layers into
two and these are the windows Azure
active directory or the wad where it
combines all the problems when it comes
to identification management ment which
is almost all file layers taken into one
and the windows asure Access Control
service enables the Federation or the
division of all these Services of an
organization and by division I mean
assigning each of these services to
these users so that is taken care of by
the windows Azor Access Control service
hence Azor active directory is able to
simplify a lot of the problems that
Windows a your active directory had for
example the application Office 365 uses
a your active directory to manage user
identities here's how now you're an
employee who wants to access one of The
Office 365 Services which could be Excel
PowerPoint Microsoft Word or something
like that so you go talk to the
administrator and he gives you access to
these services with the help of a single
username and password now as long as you
have this username and password and the
administrator has given you access to it
you can use any of these services so
who's the service audience who is using
the ACT active directory service now
there are three types of audience when
it comes to your zor active directory
the first one is it administrator the
second one application developers and
online customers so the it
administrators their main emphasis is to
ensure that the sign in takes place they
take care of all the signin procedures
they also solve issues when it comes to
authentication for example to
authenticate a particular user the
problem is solved by the it
administrators then you have application
developers who use these services to
develop applications and with this they
have a easier time developing
applications as all these resources are
easily available you have online
customers who make use of services like
Office 365 and other CRM services and
have all their demands catered
immediately so now let's have a look at
how we can use Azure active directory to
provide access to a particular
individual so if you log into the aure
account this is what you see or you go
into active directory a list of all the
people who are using or have been given
permission to use resources from aard
okay now we're going to create a profile
we need to set up his name is John and
second name
Jacob now for properties we need to
determine the source of authority which
is already the active directory so
that's fine we can select a group or add
them to a particular group if we feel
like it now if we add them to a
particular group it means that they have
access to all the resources that
everyone in the group has access to
earlier so we do that later we'll select
their directory role or we can select it
here if we need to could be user
administrator or a limited administrator
and now we'll set up a password we
already got one and we'll
create and that's it we have created a
user now we'll go to the
profile so what we can see here is that
you have access to every bit of detail
related to this account so you have the
name your first name the username the
object ID job info everything you can
even have other details like how often
they've signed in when did they sign up
you can check their password you can
reset the password delete their account
and so much more now we can even add a
directory role which we saw earlier and
now let's add this person to the admin
group so you know he gets access to all
the services that those people have
access to and select that's it we've
added them now the other things that you
can see here there are applications
licenses devices these are all
restrictions you can add or remove like
which device you can use the system
through or with and stuff like that so
that's it and with that we've created a
user and given him access to certain
Services now move on to a your virtual
machine before that let's consider a
scenario Rachel had to host 10 virtual
machines at once for a project there was
an issue when her computer RAM was not
compatible with the instances the
computer RAM was only 8GB and the
instances that required with 10gb then
she says I wish there is a service
that's cost effective and also provides
extra RAM memory one of her colleague
heard this and he comes up with an idea
he says can we use AO virtual machine it
has a pay as you go pricing and has
discs for storage you can pay for what
you use and create any number of
instances with high storage capacity
also if any technical difficulty arises
you can easily retrieve the files
through the backup server so now she's
happy and she wants to know more about
Azo viral machine Azo virtual machine is
one of the wide range of services that
Azo offers to create your instance a
viral machine is a computer file
typically called an image which behaves
like an actual computer it runs in a
window giving the user the same
experience on a virtual machine as they
have on the host operating system itself
multiple virtual machines can run
simultaneously on the same physical
computer each virtual machine provides
its own Hardware like CPUs memories and
other devices Azo virtual machine offers
a high range of flexibility and it
maintains the physical Hardware that
runs on it let me explain some of the
benefits of Azo virtual machine first we
have easy development and test Azo
virtual machine has a quick and easy way
to configure the computer that is
required to code and test an application
next agility and scale Azo virtual
machine is agile and the ability to
clone and spin up multiple instances of
the same virtual machine allows us to
scale services and application rapidly
efficiently and very cost effectively AO
virtual machine provides enhanced
performance demands for applications can
fluctuate so you pay for the virtual
machines you need and shut down the
unnecessary ones to save the cost AIO
virtual machines provide extended Data
Center and can be easily connected to an
organization's Network it is easy to set
up your redundant infrastructure in azer
and azir provides a full Disaster
Recovery site at a fraction of the cost
furthermore let me explain AA virtual
machine components in details viral
machine comes under the compute domain
of AUM it also offers various services
like availability sets snapshots diss
images and many other services like
hosts watching machine can be clubbed
with other services like diss images
availability sets hosts and many more so
the first component and the most
important component is the operating
system the operating system creates
connections to the remote desktop
session host there are many operating
systems available like Ubuntu Red Hat
Linux Windows Server Cent OS you can
also set the operating dis size so that
the memory is not wasted the next
component is discs a your virtual
machines use attached virtual hard dis
for storage there are two types of
virtual hard diss first is an image it
is a template for creation of new Azo
virtual machine then we have discs it is
a bootable virtual hard disk all durable
discs are backed up by Page blobs in AZ
storage there therefore the diss inherit
the benefits of blob storage High
availability durability and many more
the diss are mounted as drives on the VM
the next component is virtual Network
many components operate the virtual
machines in a scalable and secure manner
virtual networks could include equipment
such as separate Network spaces for
internet facing and backend servers load
balancers firewalls and more many of
these components are deployed into an
Azo virtual Network Azo virtual Network
provides many features such as subnet IP
address load balancer and network
security group another important
component of AO virtual machine is
avalability sets if in case there's a
slight chance there could be a failure
in physical servers then these come into
picture so in case of such failure the
AZ platform will migrate the failed
virtual machine to a healthy host to
reconstitute the VM it is highly
recommended to deploy at least two
instances of the virtual machine and
virtual machines placed on an
availability set perform identical set
of
functionalities now that we know what
Azia virtual machine is let's look into
the demo in this Demo First we are going
to create a virtual machine connect it
and then create a web server and modify
the web server and finally launch the
web application so let's go ahead into
the demo now so the first step is to log
into Microsoft Azure with your
credentials now let's click on Virtual
machines and create a new
one so I can put add
and you can use the subscription you
want either pay as a go pricing or free
tire Resource Group will create a new
one that is
payroll
one okay vir machine we can create I'm
going to use VM web
001 and then region I'll be using Okay
East
us then image I'll be using using
Windows Server R2 data
center size I'll be using B1
Ms
select
username
admin and then password of your
choice
and then I'm going to allow selected
ports and choose rdb
3389 and
next so OS this step I'll be using
standard
HGD and then yeah
next so I can see a default virtual
Network and a default submit and public
IP as well as
default then
next
you can allow for auto shutdown but
again it's entirely your
choice I'm going to select an extension
to install and I'm going to install
Microsoft
antimalware create
okay I'm going to create a few tags now
let's go ahead with
it
so I've created Five tags now review
plus
create okay so everything seems good
let's create
now so the deployment is going to take a
few minutes let's wait for
it
okay so that's done now let's go to
watching machine and see our watching
machine okay so it's been
deployed now let's get into the watching
machine and copy the IP
address then hit Windows plus
r and open
mstsc
and paste the IP address and connect
let's use a different account you have
to use the administrator account that
we' created before with the same
password click
okay now the remote desktop session host
opens the next step is to click on C on
server
manager and add rules and
features click on
next select Ro base or feature based
installation and click on
next then select the watching machine
you've created and next and then we are
going to
select web server IIs
next
sorry
next okay so it's already installed my
computer but you have to install this
then let's close
this and open Internet
Explorer let's type in
HTTP Local
Host yeah so now we can see the default
result opening let's minimize
this and let's try it
here here you have to just put the IP
address think there's an
issue okay so let's add an inbound Port
networking select networking and add
inbound port
let's move
480 and
add okay so it's added now let's go and
refresh
it now we can see the default web
browser opening so the next step is to
modify the web browser let's go ahead
with that go back to your remote session
host let's go file
explorer so certain folders are created
in the C drive let's open that it would
be under in
Pub so this is where the default BR is
coming from now let's make a new text
document open that and
put
hello
welcome to this
demo by simply
learn
save
it close it let's rename this
as
index.
HD
sorry
mail so this is a text document so we
need to change
that
let's REM
this okay that's
done now let's go back to our Internet
Explorer and hit
F5 let's refresh
this let's tryangle Okay
so
yeah so it's done now let's go back to
the previous browser and try let's
refresh yeah that's done first of all
let's look into why is azour virtual
Network
important so why Azure virtual network
is required so somewhere far away at an
office a company was struggling with few
challenges the company got a bigger
projects which lead to the following
challenges that includes poor network
connectivity timec consuming process in
building Network topologies could not
divert Network traffic to its
destination on time so these were a
couple of challenges the company was
facing so the employees thought that
what could be the possible solution to
these
challenges and then we require the Azure
virtual Network in that case so first of
all let's understand what is azure
virtual network is and Azure vet or a
virtual Network represents your network
or environment to run VMS and
applications in the the
cloud when it is created the services
and virtual machines within the network
interact securely with each over the
Internet so virtual Network you can
consider it as a virtual Cloud which is
basically kind of a cloud space
virtually assigned to the users or or to
the organization which they can
dedicatedly use for their purpose so for
example if you have to create some uh
instances or virtual machines on to the
Azure cloud and you want to connect it
with the on-prem servers for example uh
then you might require the virtual
Network in that case let's assume that
those instances that are created in the
virtual Network require the range of IP
addresses that you want to allocate to
them and that is something you can
customize using the Azure virtual
Network how do you want that the traffic
should be routed to your instances in
the virtual Network how the firewalls
Securities should be applied everything
the end user can control in the virtual
Network so it seems like that you are
working in your own data center ideally
you would be working onto the Azure
Cloud using the virtual Network now what
are the advantages of using the Azure
virtual Network so a couple of them are
it provides an isolated environment for
your application so as I said that it
feels like it seems like that you are
working in your on-prem environment that
means within your data center but
ideally it is a virtual space that is
allocated to you which is a kind of an
isolated environment uh that is
specifically designed for your task and
the activities a generally a subnet in a
vnet can access the public internet by
default so we create a subnet inside the
virtual Network which can access the
public internet so there is a public
network connectivity that is enabled in
the virtual net so that a subnet which
will be created in the beet can be
accessed traffic can be easily filtered
from different resources so you can have
some uh control lists defined you can
have some security groups created and
how do you want to allow the traffic
onto the servers or the application that
is something which you can control it is
a highly secure network and the security
groups and the policies are basically
implemented by the end user so you can
design how the security should be
implemented High network connectivity so
you have a higher bandwidth as compared
to the normal internet connection you
might be having in the data center
compared to that you use the Azure
Network only which gives you the higher
network connectivity it builds
sophisticated Network topologies in a
simple Manner and which is easily
manageable as well as there are less
troubleshooting issues that we would
encounter now what are the components of
azure virtual Network one of them is the
subnets then you have
routing then you have network security
groups now what do we mean by
subnets the subnet is one of the major
or a prime important component in the
virtual Network so what you have to do
is first obviously you would be creating
a virtual Network inside that you can
create the subnets subnets you can
consider it a logical partitioning or
virtual partitioning ins inside the
virtual Network subnet lets user segment
the virtual Network into one or more sub
networks for example let's assume that
you're working in an organization and in
the organization there are different
departments for every Department there
should be some set of IP addresses that
you want to allocate to the machines
that the employees are using or all the
department should be isolated that means
they should have their own network IDs
and the network address addresses
allocated to their machines and in that
case what you would do is you would
create the subnets and the subnet IDs
that would be allocated to those
departments these subn networks can be
separated logically and each subnet
consist of a server so what you do is
when you create a subnet you can uh you
can create a server or an instance
inside that subnet and how do you want
to give an access to that instance
depends on criteria or the requirement
hence a subnet can further be divided
into two parts one as the public subnet
and the other one as the private subnet
these are the naming conventions of the
subnet then how do you want to give the
internet connectivity depends on how the
public subnet should be interacting with
the internet and for the private subnet
as the name suggests that the internet
is blocked so that means it is
completely isolated in the virtual
Network the private instances though if
you want that any instance created in
the private subnet should have the
internet connectivity or an access you
can primar go with the N gateways in
that case which is a network address
translation or kind of a translator
which converts the private to public and
visce
Versa and that would actually enable the
internet connectivity to your subnets
then in the public instances they can
directly access the instance as the name
suggest public instances that public
subnets that means they have the direct
internet connectivity next component is
routing and the routing is primarily a
routing rules you can say that are
applied and those are actually applied
to the routers only so since on the
cloud we cannot have a direct router
access and hence using the routing as a
component we can Define some routing
rules which are directly applied to the
router in the
infrastructure it delivers the data by
choosing a suitable path from source to
destination for each subnet Azure
virtual Network automatically routes
traffic and creates a route table when
you create a virtual Network
automatically a route table is created
and that basically is required to Route
the traffic and that can be used by
every subnet that doesn't mean that you
only have to create a single route table
in the virtual Network you can have
multiple route tables also created which
can be associated with different subnets
as well then you have the network
security groups uh it is kind of a
firewall that protects the virtual
machine by limiting the net Network
traffic it restricts inbound and
outbound Network traffic depending upon
the destination IP address port and the
protocol so it is basically um the
network security group sits on the
instances and uh or virtual machines and
they basically Define that how the
traffic should be reaching to the ports
onto the virtual machine so how do you
want to open up the ports and for which
IP addresses you want to open up the
ports that is something the end user or
the administrator has to specify or it
design so they act as a kind of a
firewall rules only that protects the
virtual
machines so how to launch an instance
using Azure vet so first of all you have
to create a virtual Network so virtual
Network act as a container for subnets
so first thing is that you would be
creating a virtual Network then you
would be creating subnets which are
considered as a subset within the
virtual Network so cloud instan is
included in the subnet so first wets are
created then the subnets are created and
then you configure the properties in the
security group have a look at this in
detail now with respect to the virtual
Network what you need to do is you have
to create a virtual Network in the Azure
Cloud then you have to create subnets
into each virtual Network which is kind
of a subset of a virtual Network so you
can create one as a public subnet the
other one as a private subnet for
example now you have to assign instances
so when you create an instance you have
to specify that what is the virtual
Network for which virtual Network you're
creating an instance within that virtual
Network you have to select that on which
particular subnet the instance should be
created and then connect instance to a
relevant network security group so
attach your network security group to
the instances and based on the
properties or the rules that are defined
in the network security group that will
be applied to the instances within the
subnets finally configure the properties
in the network security and set the
policies as a result you'll be able to
launch your instance on Azure within the
virtual Network now we will be seeing
one demo that how we can create Azure
virtual Network subnets and the network
security group so just be there uh to
watch our demo on the Azure virtual
Network in today's session I would be
showing how you can create the virtual
networks onto the Azure and for that you
require the credentials on Microsoft
Azure and here you can see on my screen
that I have already logged in into the
Azure console now what you need to do is
uh in order to search virtual Network
you can type and search in the dashboard
uh in the search bar uh with respect to
the virtual
networks and here you can find uh the
virtual Network and the gateways so what
you need to do is you just have to click
on the virtual networks and then it will
give you the options to add the
components inside the virtual networks
so let me first uh open up uh the
virtual
Network right now in theory we discussed
that the virtual network comprises of
multiple components and subcomponents so
primarily is that first you have to
create a virtual Network then you have
to assign the ipv4 cidr block to the
virtual Network
and then you create the subnets inside
the network which is a subset of the
virtual Network along with that you
define the routing rules and uh likewise
you create the instances inside the
subnets that will be part of the virtual
networks so that's what we are going to
do uh in this demo so I would be adding
up a new virtual Network so you can see
here there are already two virtual
networks that have been added one is the
demo wiet which is by default so when
you created the Azure credentials the
demo virtual network was already created
by the Azure so that it can provide you
the default settings and then the test
one has been created by me and uh that's
the customized one or you can say a
non-default virtual Network so I'll I'm
going to add another wiet and U would
Define the name to it so let's wait for
the details to here so here you have to
define the virtual Network to create uh
obviously we will be going with the free
trial only and then you have to create a
resource Group so what is a resource
Group it is primarily a collection of
resources that share the same life cycle
permissions and the policies so if you
have a resource Group uh created you can
use it otherwise you can create a new
Resource Group so I already have one
that is the demo one I would be using
that in the instance details you have to
specif the name of uh the virtual
Network so these are
certain uh parameters that you have to
go with uh while defining the name so
let's say I put something like test wiet
as uh the virtual Network that I want to
create and that is you have to select a
region where you want to get that uh
created so these are the available
regions that you can select I would go
with um Us East uh East us only and then
we have to define the IP addresses also
see so in the IP addresses uh the cidr
blocks are allocated to the virtual
networks and that becomes a fixed IP
address for that wet so what you can do
is you can specify a range of IP
addresses now whenever we talk about a
virtual Network and the IP addresses we
primarily focus on the private IPS only
so this is the private IP that we are
actually uh talking about so I can
reserve some IP address cidr for our
wiet and that is the range of 40.0 z.0
sl16 I'm going to reserve so now we'll
create one subnet and uh we'll name that
subnet so as we discussed that subnets
are the subcomponents of uh the vet so
here you can see we have already created
one U subnet with the name public subnet
so likewise we can add another subnet
also and uh let's name it to something
like uh demo subnet right and the subnet
should have the IP address range and
that IP address range should be part of
the vet only in uh so same subnet
address range you would be defining in
the subnet as well so that will be 40.0
do1 dot or we can select 2.0
sl24 the rest of the things uh would be
default we are not attaching any route
table as of now so just click on okay
and here you can see that the subnet is
created now once the subnet is
created now we are going to create a
virtual machine inside that subnet and
for that we'll go to the search bar and
here we'll type virtual
machines now we'll create a virtual
machine in the same wiet that is the
test wiet and inside the demo subnet so
that our virtual machine gets the
private IP address from uh the subnet
that has been created in the wiet itself
so what you need to do is you have to
open up the the virtual machines click
on ADD and here you should add a new
virtual
machine so you should uh select the name
of the virtual machine and uh the
network details where we would be
defining the vet as well as the subnet
where the virtual machine should be
created so in the subscription we'll go
with the freetail and in the resource
Group we'll go with the demo that has
already been created we'll put a virtual
machine name uh something like uh test
uh VM and the rest of the things will be
default so we'll quickly skip the disk
check also now in the networking we
would be
selecting the test vet as our virtual
Network and in the subnet we would be
selecting the demo subnet so that is the
recently one added in the test vet and
we want that our virtual machine should
be part of that subnet only now
obviously since we are creating a
virtual machine so it should be part of
it should have the public IP also
assigned since uh from the public
network we need to access those virtual
machines so we'll keep it enabled right
and the next uh would be the default
settings that we are going to proceed
with so let's uh review all the
configurations and
then create your virtual machine
so here you can see that a virtual
machine has been created validation has
been passed and it takes couple of
minutes to get that updated so let's
wait for a few more minutes so that our
virtual machine is ready and primarily
what we want to look into is that our
virtual machine is created in a correct
wet and it gets uh the private IP
address from the subnet that has been
part of the uh vet uh which has been
defined in the creation of a virtual
machine so let's wait for a couple of
more minutes and uh we'll look into the
status of the
wi now you can see here our test virtual
machine has been created now what we
wanted to look into is that a virtual
machine is created in a correct subnet
or not and that is something which we
can validate by checking the private IP
address so it got the private IP from
the range of uh the IP address that we
have specified in the subnet now in
order to access this particular virtual
machine you have to use the public IP
since uh since uh we have to access it
from the internet so from the private IP
this virtual machine will not be
accessible so that's the reason that
when we created a virtual machine we
allocated the public IP address also for
this
instance so that is with respect to uh
the virtual Network and the
demonstration on it and how we can
create a vet and the subcomponents of
the vnet how they are associated or
interlined with each other and that
actually creates a kind of an isolated
environment on the public Cloud which
gives you the understanding that you can
work into um just like an on-prem
environment you can also check out Azure
Cloud architect CES that will help you
master the Azure infrastructure by
understanding Azure Cloud architect
Technology Solutions implementing
workloads and Security in Azure creating
and deploying apps in Azure and sec
uring data in Azo link is in the
description also do subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell icon
for more amazing and interesting
content so what is azure devops Azure
devops enables teams to organize work
collaborate on code development and
build and deploy applications using
developer Services Asha develops a
culture and set of protocols that brings
together developers project managers and
contributors to collaborate on software
development it enables businesses to
create and enhance products more quickly
than they could with traditional
software development methods you can use
Azure develop services in the cloud or
Azure develop server on
premises ashure devops has built-in
functionality that you may access via a
web browser or an ID client depending on
your business needs you can use one or
more of the following standard own
services
Azure repos Azure develops a buil-in
functionality so for Source management
of your code Azure repos offer get
repositories or team Foundation Version
Control Azure pipelines build and
release services provided by AO
pipelines to assess continuous
integration and delivery of your
applications Azo boards using Canan and
scrum methodologies Azure boards
provides a set of agile tools for for
planning and tracking for code bugs and
issues asure test plans manual and
exploratory testing and continuous
testing are among the options available
in Azure test plans for testing your
applications and at last Azure artifact
this allows teams to share packages from
public and private sources including
Marvin npm new get and more and
incorporate package sharing into their
pipelines so this brings us to the
features of devop first we have is
dashboard control you can rapidly
navigate to different regions of the
project build and manage dashboards and
set dashboard widgets using the devops
dashboard functionality then we have
improved Source control git and team
Foundation Version Control a centralized
client server system which are two
prominent methods of source control
supported by Azure develop solution to
observe change history you can add and
manage as your get tags reviews
downloads and modify files following
that we have planned and track your work
you can utilize Azure devop system to
track features requirements user stories
tasks issues and more using a variety of
work items then we have integrated
collaboration servers tool that allows
teams to collaborate throughout the
whole Azure develops feature set
including team dashboards project Wiki
discussion within work item point
and many others then we have support for
exploratory testing manual exploratory
and continuous testing are made easier
with Azure develop which include
workflow customization end to end
traceability criteria based selection
and real-time visualization that show
the test activities and at last comes
continuous integration and deployment
many developers use cicd and Asher
develops makes it so easy to do so
developers May automate various design
activities with ashop pipelines
including defining and Building
Association steps writing test
instructions and managing simultaneous
blees well this brings us to Asha devop
Services you get an integrated set of
services and tools with Asha develops to
manage your software project from
planning to development to testing and
deployment a client or server model is
used to deliver these Services many of
them are offered via a userfriendly web
interface that works with all major
browsers so Source controlle build
pipelines and work tracking are just a
few of the services that may be managed
through a client you can see the left
pane is where you access asure develop
Services as demonstrated in the figure
below so now that we have covered Azure
develop
Services let's move on to Azure develop
server Version Control reporting
requirements management project
management automated bills testing and
release management are all capabilities
of azure devop server a Microsoft
product it provides devops features and
spans the complete application cycle so
now that we know what Azure devop
services and aure develop server are so
let's have a crisp comparison between
them to know how exactly they differ
from each other despite the fact that
Azure develop service is a hosted
version of azure devop server there are
several features that differ some
functions of aure developed server
aren't available in ashure develop
services so when deciding which platform
to use or considering a transition from
on Promises to the cloud keep the
following points in mind cope and scale
data authentication users and groups and
manage user access so first is cope and
scale data Azure developed services and
Azure developed server are slightly
different organizations and projects are
currently the only alternatives for
scoping and scaling data asure develop
Services organization get their own URLs
and always have exactly one project
collection whereas deployment project
collection and projects are the three
methods for scoping and scaling data an
Azure develop server then we have
authentication to connect to Azure
developed services using the public
internet depending on your
organization's Arrangement you can use
Microsoft account credentials or Asha ad
credentials to login you can also
configure asure ad to require multiactor
authentication IP address restrictions
and other security features but you
connect to an intranet serving using
Azure develop server Windows
authentication and active directory
domain credentials are used to login so
this method is completely open and you
will never be asked to sign in next we
have users and group you may use a
similar technique to Grant access to
groups of users and Azure developed
Services Azure ad groups can be added to
Azure developed Services Group so you
must add users one at a time if you
utilize Microsoft account instead of
azure ad on the other hand by adding
active directory groups to multiple
Azure develop groups you may Grant user
access to deployment in Azure develop
server the membership of AD groups are
kept in same so users gain and lose
access to Azure develop server as
they're added and withdrawn in ab and at
last there is manage user access you
manage access to features in Azure
devops and Azure devop server by sign in
user to an access level each user in
your Azure develop Services organization
must be assigned an access level as
usual as Visual Studio subscriber sign
in asure devop Services verifies them so
without a visual studio subscription you
can give basic access to five users for
free whereas all use of ashet devop
server is on the honor System specify
the access levels on the administration
Administration page to set access levels
for users based on their license and
assign unlicensed user stakeholder
access only so now that we have covered
all the important features and concepts
of azure devop now let's move on to the
next very important aspect of azure
devop which is azure devops lab the
Azure devop lab is a place where you can
learn about software development and
operations with Azure devop Services you
can simplify and speed up the devops
process it explains how to use asure
develop services to automate software
delivery and satisfy business
requirements so to understand it in a
better way let's have a demo of asure
devops lab so let's start with our aure
devops demo so first what we need to do
is navigate to this uh website as.
microsoft. in or we can directly uh log
in through dev. aso.com also so first
what we need need to do is sign into our
Microsoft aure
account
so
after signing
in you'll be led to this page in that
you just need to click on continue and
here what you need to do is create an
organization under which you're going to
create your projects multiple projects
and you're going to attach your team
members to it or group members to it
whom you want to give the access to your
projects so what is the difference
between organization and project is if
you have given anybody access to your
organization or somebody is a part of
your organization then uh then that
particular individual will have access
to all of your projects but if you have
given somebody only access to your
project then he'll be only restricted to
that particular project he won't be able
to access any other project that is
present under that particular
organization that you both are part of
so basically organization is something
that is used to connect to groups of a
related project or somebody who is
already a part of a particular
organization so here we will give it a
name so I'm giving uh simply demo as the
organization name and here you can see
that uh the projects under this
organization will be hosted under the
South India region
and you need to enter the
capture and click on
continue just a
second so now you can see it is saying
that is taking you to an
organization okay so we already have an
organization of the same means so let's
just change it to something else let's
give it simply
demo
org so so you can see the see this thing
that it's taking to your aure develops
organization where you'll be creating
your
projects so now you can see your
organization name
here and here you just need to create a
project name so I'm giving it
uh
simply
demo
project now below you can see visibility
we can opt either public or private so
what is public or private so basically
if uh you keep it keep the project of
keep the visibility of the project
public then
once you copy this
URL so as I was saying once you copy
this URL into some other browser or in
kogito mode you will be able to have the
access to the project but if you keep
its visibility private then only the
people who have real access to your
organization or to your project will be
able to access that project or will be
able to see that project or work on
it as you can see uh public projects are
disabled for our organization so we
can't uh select public so we'll go for
private and click on create
project
now here uh you can see the homepage of
your organization where you
have this
project and here you can access the
statistics of project how it is
performing how much time you have
contributed to it or what all services
you have added to your
project and down below you'll be able to
see that there is just one member which
is the uh root user of this project and
uh once you start adding more members to
your project it will their details will
be added to this
particular block so now here you can see
these are the services boards zos
pipelines test PL and artifacts services
that is provided to you to add to your
project so now let's have a look at them
one my one so first one is boards as we
click on boards you can see multiple
options your work items Cod backlogs
Sprints queries delivery plans here you
can see this all empty as we haven't
added any servers or we haven't worked
on a project
yet so let's just click
on new work
item so here you can see one is epic
issue and task so epic is an option that
is uh you can see a pro
option for work
items so basically epic represents
business initiative to be accomplished
and it is basically available for basic
agile scrum and cmmi process
templates so what it exactly does is
increases customer engagement that
whoever whatever your project is if it's
uh the
engagement of your project that how it's
performing and how it is performing
towards the people whom you have given
access to the project also helps to
create new architecture to improve the
performance of your
project and uh it also support mobile
application so basically when you're
deploying any mobile application in your
project or creating a mobile application
as a project it will be able to support
that as well let's click on
Epic so here you can see you need to uh
enter a title for your uh epic
option so here you need to add the title
of your epic like uh for
say we are creating a healthcare or an
e-commerce application so obviously it
will be segmented into different parts
like you'll be having having search
options or Support options or homepage
so we just need to give it a
name and uh here you can see it state is
too for now we just have to do because
we haven't actually created anything in
our project and we haven't given any
input so it's in to-do list and uh once
we start working on it it gets we can
change the state it it can be in
progress all completing so there are
multiple States for your
epic and here you can see the area is
simply demo project that means that we
want to assign this search new Epic into
this project and we can also click
description over here that what exactly
our new epic is about like for search
options we need to specify or give a
description that uh this is for
searching options related to our
application
like for healthare one can
type medicines
or
doctors or slots so that is that that is
thing that we can add in a
description that it will help the user
to understand what this feature is
about so this was epic and once done we
can click on
save so here you can see other stuffs
also like
priority so we can select priority
according to
our will so here by default it is
priority 2 so priy basically is which
function will come first and here you
can mention start date Target
date so once it's done you can click on
Save now now let's
move to the next
one second what we have is
issue so basically issues are for you to
track your work and uh epics are used to
track the group work and large
scenarios but uh this is
track like like we saw the project
statistics it will help you to
understand the individual
progress so basically issues are raised
when uh you find any obstacle in your
progress or in your work so it can be
compared to impediments also so when
you're working with agile uh you need to
deal with issues so by default we have
agile to our project assign so like for
example we can see that uh we have a
meeting so during the meeting members
report if they have encountered any bug
or any any
impediments so what next we have to do
is we have to track them and resolve it
so these are the issues that can uh one
can find like possibilities so you can
assign here and give it a description
again
and just save it so once a user faces
these issues we can keep a track of it
and once it is raised we can resolve
it coming to
the next
one next we have is
task so by the name only we can uh well
understand what task
is so a task is a smaller item
or smaller segment to track activity
that contains all the information needed
to accomplish a part of a of an issue or
you can say user story requirements so
this option is available for basic agile
scrum and cmmi process
templates so again we can give it a name
what task we want to
assign and uh give it a
description and according to that we can
select the
priority and save it so the task will be
added to your
project we are not uh assigning any task
right now because as I said we haven't
added any uh particular project or
particular details or application or we
haven't deployed any application yet in
a project so that is why we are not
adding anything over here again because
first we need to understand what these
services are and what these services are
used
for next we have backlogs so backlogs
helps
you to understand the flow of your
project like today you have contributed
10% of U your time and uh you have
completed the 10% of the work or you
have worked on certain segments of the
project like for say you have worked in
the support area so it helps you
to understand and keep a track of the
flow of your project how it is
performing and how it is developing and
how it is built every day
next we have a
strength so Sprints are basically a time
box interval that supports your team's
ability to work using the agile
processes and tools so what you can do
is whether you're having let's say
you're having a healthcare application
so you just need
to have a segment of it and drop it over
here so what would what it will do is uh
it will get the attention of all the
team members so basically what it does
it it makes your project more
manageable it uh increases the quality
of your project and also makes it work
even more faster and more frequently
once you add the segment to the Sprint
so you can say it in one way it gets the
priority and people need to work on it
and it gives your project more
flexibility to adapt to
change now now sometimes what happens is
many Associates scum Sprints with agile
software development so sometimes agilea
often thought to be the same
thing coming to the next one we have
queries so the Crea p
basically remembers the view you
have last Navigator and when you log in
again or when you come back again to the
same portal it returns you to that very
particular view only so it can you can
say that it runs with Azure develops
command line
interface and uh all the open uh like
all the pages like you have gone through
you can keep a track of it over here
here you just need to click over here
all and you can just see all the queries
you have uh defined in all this while
and also you can share the queries with
the team
members so they can also know that where
you have been working
lately or which segment you have been
working on or what was the last
navigation which you have been going
through in this whole project
so it can help you manage your project
in a more efficient way and keep a track
of how and what all segments you have
been working on and what all segments
you need to work on in your
project coming to the next one we have
delivery
plans so here you can see uh we haven't
created any plan yet so basically
delivery plans are a calender view of
multiple teams or team backlogs or
individual backlogs from different
projects so basically it replaces the
delivery plans Marketplace
extension and it is only available for
Azure develop
services so here you can act you can uh
you can say it's a summary or uh time
summary of all the projects you have
been working on in a particular
organization so now that we have covered
both uh
let's move to the next one which is
repos so with the name itself we can uh
well understand that repo stands for
repositories so basically it is a set of
repositories that allows you to control
and manage your project code like for
say you're deploying a healthcare
application so these repos options help
you create repositories
and manage your code of that particular
application in more efficient way so
what you can do is you can connect
project solutions by using the repos
link uh as you can see here it is shown
so let's uh look into its option one by
one first we have files so in files your
project solution will be available in
this
section so repositories can create
manage and those
Solutions okay so you just need to
upload your
Solutions of uh your code or your
project here and uh it will just create
repositories for it and it will help you
create manage those Solutions in a
better way you see
these clone to your computer push an
existing repository from command line
and imported repositor if you want to
import any uh solution like here you can
just click on import and add the
solution to a reposit
3 so this is what files
do basically you can see it is say uh it
is a it's like a physical folder itself
where you have all your uh mini files or
repositories or Solutions you can say of
data so basically it's it functions like
a physical folder itself so it helps you
keep a track of the codes and
everything next comes is
comits so uh in commit section we can
manage commit history for your
repositories that you have created in
files so it just commits those uh
repositories with auor details from
branches like for say we have a team one
from uh sport branch and one from
management Branch so whoever creates
that repositories and the solution it
commits that repositories under that
under that particular member of the team
with the branch
name then comes
pushes
so push histories are available in this
section from each pull request done by
the developers Developers for say the
team members we who have been working on
this particular project and creating
repositories and
solutions so what is pull
request so pull request or PRS are a way
to change or review of merge code in our
repositories so basically team uses
these PR to review code and give
feedbacks or changes whether like uh for
say you are deploying a code or a
solution so one can review them what all
changes needs to be made or what all
upgradation needs to be made or whether
the code is already fine or not so
basically teams use these PRS to review
the solutions and codes stored in these
repositories or you can merge multiple
Solutions or multiple codes into the
main
branch so basically reviewers can step
through the proposed changes and leave
those comments and vote to approve or
reject that particular code or you can
say to upgrade or what all changes you
want to make it they vote for it that
whether that needs to be made to that
particular solution or not so these are
the
PRS
next uh we have branches so we can
manage multiple branching information in
this particular section you can create
create or release branches from Master
to
death okay so all users can
actually can actually uh create or
release branches from branching
information available in this particular
section next come
tags so tags are uh used to point out
specific
comments like uh giving message tags and
data information to branches you can
create your naming conventions to
branches by using
tags and uh the second the next one is
full request which we have already
discussed the PS that are basically Us
in
pushes so now we have come with uh
completed repos also so let's move on to
the next one which is
pipelines so here you can see see that
we don't have any P pipeline created for
us yet so let's have a look at it's
provided options one by one the first
one is
environments so basically it is a
collection of uh resources where you
actually deploy your application that
you're working on so it contain you can
say it contains one or more virtual
machines containers web apps Etc
whatever uh resources you have actually
used for deploying your
application or what all services you
have used
for creating the environment for the
deployment of your application for say
we need to uh deploy an uh application
and it needs an uh
Windows Java environment so whatever uh
resources you need to create that
environment that will be added to this
environment List It will be listed over
this
section next we have releases option so
basically this uh pipeline stores the
data of your pipelines or stages or task
and deployments in as your pipelines
that deployments you have done so far in
your applications for your applications
actually so you can say that uh it helps
you team continuously deliver software
to your customers at a faster Pace or
with a very minimum you can say lower
risk so it you can fully automate
and automate the testing and the
delivery of your software or
applications on uh multiple
stages or or you can also set up an
automated process with approvals and On
Demand
deployments then comes uh
Library so again you can see the pages
blank so from the name itself you can
scrutinize that it will be a
collection of assets from Azure develops
projects so basically it is a collection
of build and release assets of a
particular project so assets defined in
a library can be used in multiple bills
and multiple releases pipelines of the
project okay so all assets that are
defined in a library share a common
security model so you can control who
can Define your items in a library and
who can use an existing item that you
have already added in this
Library
roles are defined for library items for
say you have added a particular asset or
particular item to this Library
segment and you can assign a particular
member who will be working on this
item okay so roles are defined here for
these and these governs the operation
you can perform on those
items that person will be keeping track
whatever changes have been made or
whatever upgradation has been made to
the particular item that has been added
to this segment Library
segment so then comes uh task
groups so task groups are a way to
standardize and centrally manage
deployment steps for all applications in
your projects so when you include a task
group in your definition and and then
make a change centrally to the task
group the change is automatically
reflected in all the
definitions so we can conclude with this
that a task group allows you to
encapsulate a sequence of task already
defined in you can say build or release
pipelines or into a SLE task
group so it just encapsulate all those
sequen of task so you can choose to
extract the parameter from those
encapsulated task as configured
variables and Abstract the rest of the
task information so what happens is the
new task group is automatically added to
the task
catalog and uh it is ready to be added
to other release and buil pipelines so
task groups are stored at the project
level and are not accessible outside the
project group so the task groups uh will
be only limited to the members who you
have assigned in this project and it
won't be accessible to the other people
or other team members from different
projects even though they are the member
of the same organization so you can say
it's more of a
private
segment now that we have covered task
groups next we have deployment
groups so deployment groups are only
available with class clastic release
pipelines and it is totally different
from the deployment
jobs it is basically a collection of
deployment related steps defined in a yl
file to accomplish a specific task so in
nutshell it is a logical set of
deployment Target machine that have
agents installed on each one the
deployment groups represent the physical
environment for example uh testing or
development or production
environment so a Development Group is
just another grouping of Agents much
like in agent pool you can
say so what you can do with this is you
can specify the security context and
runtime targets for the agents or you
can let yourself view live logs for each
server as a deployment take
place or you can also enable you to use
machine tags to limit deployment to a
specific set of uh
servers so this was about deployment
groups now that we have covered one more
service let's move on to the next one
that is test
plans so test plans the first one we
have uh is progress
report so you can analyze with this only
the progress report will be the
progress of the project you have been
working on or the deployments you have
been doing or the task you have been
performing
so basically it lets you analyze and
view data
for more than one or an individual test
plans in a particular
project so data for test plans can
migrated can be be migrated from an on
premises Azure develop server that won't
show up in this report
okay so basically this section lets you
drill down by each test plans and give
you summary of each test plan in it this
section also lets you to navigate to a
test plan or suit of Choice by double
clicking on it
okay so this was the progress report
next we have
runs so basically it represents the
execution of pipelines during a run the
pipeline is processed and agents process
one or more
jobs so when you run a pipeline many
things happen under the CLE while you
often won't need to know about them
occasionally it's usual to have the
bigger picture
right
so as your
pipelines will get processed under
this test runs segment so you'll be able
to see what
performance is happening over here like
while you're running a pipeline you can
see uh the running
State the uh the date you have started
that or what all that running pipeline
includes like jobs steps and task so
runs power both continuous integration
and continuous delivery
pipelines next we have load
test so basically as your load testing
is a fully managed as asure service that
enables developers and testers to
generate High scale load with custom
Apache J met strips and gain actionable
insight to catch and fix performance
bottlenecks at scale so basically
application performance and resiliency
are more important than ever
before so how you can run and aure
devops
test so first you need to click on it
and select a test suit that contains all
the automated
test and uh you can just choose the run
test
option and it will start processing so
the service this service basically
simulates traffic for your application
you can say regardless of on which
platform or where it is actually
hosted so now that we have covered test
plans as well let's move on to the next
one that is artifacts so this is the
last service that is provided to your
project by Asha
devops so artifacts is a byproduct
produced during the software development
process so it mainly consists of the
project source code dependency or
binaries or resources that could be
represented in different layout
depending on the particular
technology so it's like an extension
that makes it easier to discover install
or
publish and may even packages in as your
devops it's basically deeply integrated
with other hubs like build so that
package management can become a seamless
part for your existing
workflows so what is exactly it is used
for so it basically it can be used for
both public and private organization
with teams of any size it it
basically manages
your npm or new get packages via feeds
and it allows you to create and share
your
M so it's a package management solution
integrated with your as your
device so this was all about the
services that is provided to your
projects so now that you know what all
services do for your project and what
are their benefits and how they function
now you can actually plan your project
and start creating and working on it and
start deploying with the users and what
all services you want for your
particular project so what you can do is
uh click here on Project
setting just a
second yeah you can just click on
Project setting
so now what you can do is you can add in
description that uh what your actual
project is about so for say like I said
if you're creating in a healthcare
application so you can just give with
the description that it is for
healthcare related the issues queries
and helps needed and like you're tying
that particular application with
different hospitals or Healthcare
organization so you can actually add
those information in this
description and the process basically it
is basic for private one uh but you do
get a range of uh process for your
project when it depending on the
visibility of it like for H or scum you
can
say so now here you can see that only my
uh ID is attached to it as I'm the only
member here and I'm the administrator so
you can add members here and scrolling
down you can now that you know what all
services uh provide you or what they
provide to your project depending on the
need of your project you can
just uh select the services you want to
assign to your particular project like
for say if I don't want BS assigned to
it or you can say if I don't want the
services provided by the coach you can
just click on it and select like remove
both and I just need to refresh
it so yeah here you can see I have
overview
repost pipelines artifacts but I don't
have uh test plans and Boards as you can
say test plans is basically all the
collection of whatever you're managing
which is indirectly assigned to the
boards so as you remove the boards of
the test PL also get removed okay and
once like this you can just uh select
what all services you want specifically
and if you want to delete your project
you can just go ahead and delete it so
this was all about the aure devop
services and aure the work Studio we can
say and how the demonstration of how a
project actually functions in you can
also check out a Azure Cloud architect
course that will help you master the
Azure infrastructure by understanding
Azure Cloud architect Technology
Solutions implementing workloads and
Security in Azure creating and deploying
apps in Azure and securing data in Azure
link is in the description also do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon for more amazing and
interesting content you can also check
out a azure aure Cloud architect course
that will help you master the Azure
infrastructure by understanding Azure
Cloud architect Technology Solutions
implementing workloads and Security in
Azo so what are you waiting for check
out the link mentioned in the
description box for more details on AWS
versus Azure versus gcp talking about
market share Amazon web services leads
with around 32% of the worldwide public
cloud share aour owns up to 16% of the
worldwide market share and gcp owns
around 9% of the world's market share
let's talk about each of these service
providers in detail AWS provides
services that enable users to create and
deploy applications over the cloud these
services are accessible via the Internet
AWS being the oldest of the lot was
launched in the year 2006 a launched in
2010 is a Computing platform that offers
a wide range of services to build manage
and deploy applications on the network
using tools and Frameworks launched in
the year 2008 gcp offers application
development and integration services for
its end users in addition to Cloud
management it also offers services for
Big Data machine learning and iot now
let's talk about availability zones
these are isolated locations within data
center regions from which public cloud
services originate and operate talking
about AWS they have 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical regions
this includes regions in the United
States South America Europe and Asia
Pacific they're also predicted to have
12 more additions in the future Azure a
aable in 140 countries has over 54
regions worldwide grouped into six
geographies these geographical locations
have more than 100 data centers gcp is
available in 200 plus countries across
the world as of today gcp is present in
61 zones and 20 regions with Osaka and
Zurich being the newly added regions now
let's talk about pricing these Services
follow the pay as you go approach you
pay only For The Individual Services you
need for as long as you use them without
requiring long-term contracts or complex
licensing now on screen you can see the
pricing for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and GPU now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for AWS we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in Hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azour virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that Azure offers Azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcps VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these Services aw cc2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's freeer
that lasts for 12 months and provides
750 hours per month of both Linux and
Windows Virtual machines Azure virtual
machines service is a part of the free
tier that offers this service for about
750 hours per month for a year the user
gets access to Windows and Linux virtual
machines gcps VM service is a part of a
free tier that includes micro instance
per month for up to 12 months now let's
talk about platform as a service or past
services for AWS elastic bean stock is
an easy to use service for deploying and
scaling web applications and services
developed with Java net nodejs Python
and much more it is used for maintaining
Capac capacity provisioning load
balancing autoscaling and application
Health monitoring the pass backbone
utilizes virtualization techniques where
the virtual machine is independent of
the actual Hardware that hosts it hence
the user can write application code
without worrying about the underlying
Hardware Google app engine is a cloud
computing platform as a service which is
used by Developers for hosting and
building apps in Google data centers the
app engine requires the apps to be
written in Java or Python and store data
in Google big table and use the Google
query language for this next let's talk
about virtual private server Services
AWS provides light sale it provides
everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM image is a more comprehensive image
for Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their choice gcp Cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build event-driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fall tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers First off we
have object storage AWS provides S3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in Microsoft's Cloud
platform along with storage it also
offers scalability it stores the data in
the form of tiar depending on how often
data is being accessed Google Cloud
Storage is an online storage web service
for storing and accessing data on Google
Cloud platform infrastructure unlike the
Google Drive Google Cloud Storage is
more suitable for Enterprises it also
stores objects that are organized into
buckets Amazon provides EBS or elastic
Block store it provides high performance
block storage and is used along with E2
instances for workloads that are
transaction or throughput intensive
Azure manage dis is a virtual hard disk
you can think of it like a physical dis
in an on premises server but virtualized
these managed discs allow the users to
create up to 10,000 VM discs in a single
subscription persistent storage is a
data storage device that retains data
after power to the device is shut off
Google persistent disk is durable and
high performance block storage for gcp
persistent disk provides storage which
can be attached to instances running in
either Google compute engine or cubes
engine next up we have Disaster Recovery
Services AWS provides a cloud-based
recovery service that ensures that your
it infrastructure and data are recovered
while minimizing the amount of downtime
that could be experienced site recovery
helps ensure business continuity by
keeping business apps and workloads
running during outages it allows
recovery by by orchestrating and
automating the replication process of
azure virtual machines between regions
unfortunately gcp has no disaster
recovery service next let's talk about
database Services first off for AWS we
have RDS or relational database service
it is web service that's coste effective
and automates administration tasks
basically it simplifies the setup
operation and scaling of a relational
database Microsoft Azure SQL database is
a software as a service platform that
includes built-in intellig
that learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the users applications
cloudsql is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational post SQL MySQL
and SQL Server databases in the cloud
hosted on gcp cloudsql provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have no SQL
database Services AWS provides Dynamo DB
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup into store and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance Azure Cosmos DB is
Microsoft's globally distributed
multimodel database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by Google Google on the gcp it
handles replication and scales
automatically to your application's load
with cloud data stores interface data
can easily be accessed by any deployment
Target now let's talk about the key
Cloud tools for each of these service
providers for AWS in networking and
content delivery we have AWS Route 53
and AWS cloudfront for management we
have AWS Cloud watch and AWS cloud
formation for development we have AWS
code start and AWS code buil for
security we have IM am and Key
Management Service for Microsoft roft
Azure networking and content delivery we
have content delivery Network and
express Ru for management tools we have
Azure advisor and network Watcher for
development tools for management we have
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and Azure blob studio for security we
have Azure security Center and Azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have Cloud CDN and
Cloud DNS for management we have stack
driver and gcp monitoring for de
velopment we have Cloud build and Cloud
SDK and finally for security we have
Google cloud IM and Google and Cloud
security scanner now let's talk about
the companies using these Cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix unila
kellogs NASA Nokia and adobi pixa
Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW among
others use Microsoft Azure so as seen on
your screens the companies that use gcp
are Spotify HSBC Snapchat Twitter PayPal
and 20th C Cy Fox let's talk about the
advantages of each of these Services
Amazon provides Enterprise friendly
Services you can leverage Amazon's 15
years of experience delivering large-
scale Global infrastructure and it still
continues to hone and innovate its
infrastructure management skills and
capabilities secondly it provides
instant access to resources AWS is
designed to allow application providers
isvs and vendors to quickly and securely
host your applications whether an
existing application or a new SAS based
application Speed and Agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what you require and you can proceed you
can access each of these applications
anytime you need them and finally it's
secure and reliable Amazon enables you
to innovate and scale your application
in a secure environment it secures and
hardens your infrastructure more
importantly it provides security at a
cheaper cost than on promise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure Microsoft Azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
azure aure has a strong focus on
security following the Standard Security
model of detect assess diagnose
stabilize and close Azure also provides
a cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves on it
infrastructure costs hence it's Opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp Google builds in
minute level increments so you only pay
for the compute time you use they also
provide discounted prices for long
running workloads for example you use
the VM for a month and get a discount
gcp also provides live migration of
virtual machines live migration is the
process of moving a running VM from one
physical server to another without
disrupting its availability to the users
this is a very important differentiator
for Google Cloud compared to other Cloud
providers gcp provides automatic
scalability this allows a sight
container scale to as many CPUs as
needed Google Cloud Storage is designed
for 99.9% durability it creates server
backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for AWS there's a limitation of the ec2
service AWS provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee AWS charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs $29 per month business which
costs more than $100 and ENT rice that
costs more than $115,000 it has certain
network connectivity issues it also has
General issues when you move to the
cloud like downtime limited control
backup protection and so on however most
of these are temporary issues and can be
handled over time talking about some of
the disadvantages of Microsoft Azure
codebase is different when working
offline and it requires modification
when working on the cloud pass ecosystem
is not as efficient as IAS Azure
Management console is frustrating to
work with it is slow to respond and
update and requires far too many clicks
to achieve simple tasks Azure backup is
intended for backing up and restoring
data located on your on premises servers
to the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
Cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around $150 per month
for the most basic service similar to
AWS S3 gcp has a complex pricing schema
also it is not very budget friendly when
it comes to downloading data from Google
Cloud Storage we'll go over the
Microsoft aure certification test in
this video and present useful
information to assess you to decide on a
CER path Microsoft offers three
certification paths for a variety of
technical jobs to gain certification you
must complete a series of exams and the
first one is fundamentals certification
these certifications are suitable for
those who are just getting started in
technology are considering a career
shift second is role based certification
to begin acquiring valuable job role
abilities choose a role based
certification third is additional
certification examine Microsoft Office
technical qualifications as well as
specialist and Microsoft certified
educator certifications now in each
category we have sorted the
certifications for your better
understanding in the first category
fundamental certification are Microsoft
certified Azure fundaments Microsoft 365
certified fundamentals and Microsoft
certified Power Platform fundamentals in
the second category role based
certifications are Microsoft 365
certified Security administrator
associate Microsoft certified aure
developer associate and Microsoft
certified Dynamics 365 sales functional
consultant associate and in the third
category additional certifications are
Microsoft certified asure for sap
workload specialty Microsoft certified
educator and Microsoft Office specialist
Microsoft Word expert so let's start
with the first one Microsoft certified
Azure fundamentals the Azure fundamental
certification allows you to demonstrate
that you understand Cloud Concepts as
your services as your workloads as your
security and privacy and as your pricing
and support candidates should have basic
understanding of technical fundamentals
such as networking storage computation
application support and application
development candidates for the Asher
fundamental certification should have a
solid understanding of cloud services
and how Microsoft ashure deliver them
this certification is for applicants who
are new to ashure or who are just
starting to work with cloudbased
Solutions and services moving ahead
let's look into its skills requirement
describe Cloud Concepts describe core
Azure Services describe core Solutions
and management tools on ashure describe
general security and network security
features describe identity governance
privacy and compliance features and
describe asure cost management and
service level agreements this
certification is suitable for job roles
like administrator business user
developer student technology manager and
its exam code is AZ 900 price of this
examination is 99 USD and the renewable
time is 2 years coming to the next one
is the Microsoft 365 certified
fundamental certification it verifies
that you are familiar with Microsoft 365
feature and benefits as well as the
advantages of using cloud services the
software as a service cloud model and
the Microsoft 365 cloud service these
are the skills required to earn this
certification describe Cloud Concepts
describe core Microsoft 365 services and
Concepts explain security compliance
privacy and Trust in Microsoft 365 and
describe Microsoft 365 pricing and
support this certification is apt for
job roles like business user and
administrator and the exam code for this
examination is ms9900 the examination
fee is $99 USD and the renewable time is
2 years next is Microsoft certified
Power Platform fundamentals if you're a
student a business user or a new
technical professional using your
Microsoft Power Platform skills to
better your team's efficiency this
certification can help you advance your
career to prepare for it you only need a
basic understanding of computer
technology data analytics cloud
computing and the internet consider a
fundamental CER certification the
initial step towards expanding your
skill set and moving on to more advanced
certifications like Microsoft Power
Platform functional consultant and the
skill set required for this
certification are describe the business
value of Power Platform identify the
core components of Power Platform
demonstrate the capabilities of Power
Platform describe the capabilities of
power apps demonstrate the capabilities
of power automate demonstrate the
business value of power ual agents this
certification is perfect for job roles
like business user functional consultant
student and its exam code is PL 900 the
examination fee for this exam is 99 USD
and its renewable time is 2 years now
let's dive into the second category
which was Role based certification the
first certification exam in this
category is Microsoft 365 certified
Security administrator associate
Microsoft 365 security administrators
protect Microsoft 365 Enterprise and
hybrid environments by proactively
securing them and implementing and
managing security and compliant
Solutions responding to threats and
enforcing data governance policy this
exam accesses your ability to use
Microsoft 365 to implement and manage
identity and access thread protection
information security and governance and
compliance features the skills required
for this certification are Implement and
manage identity and access Implement and
manage threat protection Implement and
manage information protection manage
governance and compliance features in
Microsoft 365 now this certification is
perfect for the administrator role and
its exam code is ms500 its examination
fee is 165 USD and its renewal time is
again 2 years then comes Microsoft oft
certified as your developer associate
candidates for the user developer
associate certification should have
experience designing developing testing
and supporting Microsoft as your Cloud
applications and services participating
in all aspects of cloud development from
requirements definition and design to
development deployment and maintenance
as well as performance tuning and
monitoring is part of its role
responsibility ities now the skill set
essential for the certification are
develop Azure compute Solutions develop
for Azure storage Implement Azure
security monitor troubleshoot and
optimize Azure Solutions connect to and
consume Azure services and third party
Services now this certification is for a
job role like developer and its exam
code is a204 its examination fee is 165
USD with a renewal time of 2 years
moving on next is Microsoft certified
Dynamics 365 sales functional consultant
associate this certification could help
you advance in your career if you're
functional consultant a Microsoft
Dynamics 365 sales professional or a
developer wishing to improve your
Consulting skills it enables you to
better pitch yourself for projects and
demonstrates to your company how
Dynamics 365 sales can be used to
empower Sal people you have expertise
with Microsoft Power Platform and are
familiar with Dynamic 365 model driven
apps and data modeling techniques as a
candidate for this certification for
this certification skills required are
perform configuration manage core sales
tables configure additional tools and
services configure Microsoft data wor
create apps by using Microsoft power
apps create and manage Microsoft power
automate Implement Microsoft power
virtual agents chatbots integrate
Microsoft power apps with other apps and
services and manage Solutions now this
certification is suitable for the
functional consultant profile and the
exam code for this exam are PL 200 and
mb210 the examination fee for this exam
is 165 USD and the renewal time is 2
years now comes the third category
additional certification and the first
certification exam in this category is
my Microsoft certified Azure for sap
workloads specialty Architects or
Engineers with substantial experience
and knowledge of the sap system
landscape and Industry standards that
are particular to the initial migration
or integration as well as the long-term
operation of an SCP Solution on
Microsoft Azure should apply for this
certification making recommendations on
services and modifying resources as
needed for optimal resiliency
performance scale provision size and
monitoring are among the
responsibilities of an architect or
engineer for Azure for sap workloads
skills required for this certification
are migrate sap workloads to aure design
and Implement an infrastructure to
support sap workloads design and
Implement High availability and Disaster
Recovery maintain sap workloads on Azure
now this certification is perfect for
job roles like administrator solution
architect and its exam code is
a120 its exam fee is 165 USD with the
renewal time of 2 years then comes
Microsoft certified educator the
Microsoft certified educator MCE
credential verifies that teachers
possesses the global educator technology
literacy competencies required to
provide students with a rich
personalized learning experience
Educators in training instructors at
teachers education colleges and
inservice Educators all benefit from MC
certification so these are the skills
required facilitate student
collaboration skilled communication
self-regulation real world problem
solving and Innovation facilitate
student use of information and
communication tools and use ICT to Be an
Effective educator now this
certification suitable for developer and
educator profiles and its exam code is
62193 its examination fee is 127 USD and
its renewal time is 2 years now comes
the last but not the least one in this
category and it is Microsoft Office
specialist Microsoft Word expert earn
the Microsoft Office specialist word
expert certification to show that you
have the skills needed to get the most
out of word this credential demonstrate
Proficiency in the the creation and
management of professional papers for a
variety of purposes and scenarios the
skills essential to gain this
certification are manage document
options and settings use of advanced
editing and formatting features creating
a custom document elements and use
Advanced word features now this
certification is suitable for job
profiles like business users and its
exam code is M101 the exam fee for this
certification is 100 USD and its renewal
time is 2 years so this was all about as
your certification pass apart from this
not only will you need to learn how to
design manage and protect Azure Cloud
systems in order to become certified and
land a job but you'll also need real
hands-on experience like to welcome you
to this Azure interview preparation
session knowing Azure is one thing
having worked on Azure is another thing
and being able to answer interview
questions in Azure is a totally
different thing although one helps the
other it's still different skills and
our aim through this video is to prepare
you with common product and scenario
based interview questions so why wait
let's get started a common Cloud
interview question is what's the
difference between SAS Pas and is we all
know that a software as a service is
Thin Client model of software
provisioning where Cent In this case
usually is simply a web browser
providing the point of access to
softwares running on the servers now SAS
is the most familiar form of cloud
service for customers SAS moves the task
of managing software and its deployment
to third party Services meaning the
vendor actually gets to manage all that
so uh SAS is software as a service
involving applications being consumed
and used by organization so it's
generally using an application and
usually organizations pay for their use
of this particular application now some
examples of SAS would include Office 365
Salesforce is another very good example
of SAS and a lot of uh Google Apps and
Storage Solutions like box and Dropbox
are a very good example of software as a
service talking about platform as a
service or PAs it actually functions at
the lower level than SAS now typically
it provides a platform on which software
can be developed and deployed now here
we develop the software we deploy the
software now Pas actually provides an
abstract of much of the work dealing
with servers and giving client an
environment in which the operating
system and the server software and the
Hardwares the network or managed and
taken care in other words with a
platform as a service all the things
things that I've mentioned like the
servers the server software the hardware
everything is managed by the provider
and we can focus on business side of the
scalability and we can focus on
application development of our product
or the service so in short platform as a
service is a service that enables
developers to build and work with
applications without even having to
worry about the infrastructure or
management of the underlying hosting
envirment nments and some examples of
pass in Azure is SQL and Azure storage
talking about infrastructure as a
service I as now this is moving down the
stack even further now we get to the
fundamental building block of the cloud
service which is infrastructure as a
service I now IAS is fully of Highly
automated scalable Computer Resources is
is full of storage I is full of the
network NW workk capability that's what
is is now is clients have direct access
to the servers and storage just as they
would to do traditional servers but in
this case it's going to be in the cloud
in this case it's going to be more
scalable so I is very similar to what
you would do in your on premises
physical data center but when we talk
about is we get to do everything but
it's stored in the cloud so if we need
to build a definition around I I or
infrastructure as a service provides
users with components it provides
components it does not give us an built
environment it simply provides a
component such as operating system uh
networking capabilities and a lot more
now this is a paid for based on the
usage and can be used to host
applications in other words this is pay
as you go type the more you use the more
you pay the less you use the less you
pay and some of the examples of I in
Azure is virtual machine that's a great
example for I as and v-ets for
networking that's another good example
for I in Azure another common question
in Azure interview is what are the
instant types offered by Azure the main
intention of this question is how well
have you understood the different
offerings in Azure and how well are you
trained to pick the right offering for
the right service now one size does not
fit all and there of there are a lot of
services in Azure that under the carpet
it does the same thing but depending on
how different your requirement is we'll
have to pick the appropriate service so
this actually this question what are the
different instant types offered by Azure
it's to test how well have you used the
product and services available in Azure
and how well have you applied them for
the given requirement you shouldn't be
provisioning more you shouldn't be
provisioning less at the same time so
it's kind of matching the right service
to the right requirement so what are the
instant types offered by Azure as as you
see in the list we have general purpose
computer optimized memory optimized
storage optimized GPU virtual machines
and high performance compute virtual
machines now answering just the names
won't be enough in an interview you'll
have to go further and explain why and
in What scenario you would use general
purpose and what are the use cases what
type of servers is a good fit for a
general purpose and what type is a good
fit for computer optimized so on and so
forth and that's exactly what we're
going to do now so the general purpose
VMS you know they provide a balanced CPU
to memory ratio and it's very good for
testing very good for development
environment very good for small and
medium databases and also for low to
medium traffic web servers and some of
the use cases are like we said test
servers low traffic web servers small to
medium databases some Enterprise grade
applications it's also good for
relational database it's also Al good
for uh servers used for inmemory caching
it's also good for some small analytic
uh database very good for microservices
and if you're trying to build a proof of
concept for an idea that you just have
or just parked uh this is another good
server for doing proof of Concepts
because you're not going to send actual
traffic to it I just want to show that
you know your idea works so general
purpose server is a very good use case
for those scenarios and the largest
instance size uh we can get in general
purpose is standard d64 V3 uh which
comes with 256 GB of memory and, 1600 GB
of SSD temporary storage on the other
hand Compu optimized VMS have an a high
CPU to memory ratio and are very good
for medium traffic web servers very good
for batch processing servers very good
for application servers now because it's
compute optimized and compute means a
CPU it's an excellent choice for
workloads that demand faster CPU but
does not need as much memory or
temporary storage virtual CPU some of
the workloads that run very well on
computer optimized are analytic
workloads a gaming servers require more
CPU they run really well uh batch
processing are some of the applications
that can be placed in computer optimized
and by doing that we get the actual
benefit of the computer optimized uh
instance and the largest instance size
or the largest instance size type is
standard f72 V2 and here we get 144 GB
of memory and 576 GB of SSD temporary
storage in compute optimized VMS in the
same lines memory optimized VM they
offer High memory to CPU ratio and that
are great for databases databases
require more memory so it's a great fit
for database base and uh it's a great
fit for medium to large scale caches
applications that require inmemory
analytics so this memory optimized
memories more so it's very good for
inmemory analytics applications and the
largest instant size we get here is
standard m128 M and look at the um
gigabit of memory it's
3,892 GB of memory and uh look at the uh
temporary storage it's uh 4 100
336 GB of temporary storage on the same
lines storage optimized now I guess I
don't have to explain to you what
storage optimized is used for you might
have easily guessed looking at the flow
yes storage optimized Wim offer High
disk throughput and IO and are very
ideal for Big Data uh SQL no SQL
databases data warehousing servers large
transactional databases and a lot more
and some of the examples of the
applications that can be launched on
storage optimized are Cassandra mongod
DB Cloud era redis these are some
familiar applications that can get
benefited when we run them on storage
optimized and one difference between
storage optimized and the other servers
are they are generally optimized to use
the local dis on the Node attached
directly to the VM rather than using an
durable dis which is actually and a
remote uh disk space now what does this
allow this allows for greater input
outputs per second or uh throughput for
the workload so that's what we get a
greater throughput a greater input
outputs per second is what we get when
we use storage optimized and the largest
instant size available in storage
optimized is uh standard uh l32 s and uh
uh the memory is 256 GB and look at the
temporary storage it's uh
5630 GB of temporary storage GPU type
VMS easy to guess GPU optimized VMS are
specialized virtual machines available
with uh multiple gpus attached to them
now these sizes are designed for or
these VMS are designed for computer
intensive graphic intensive
visualization workflows that require lot
of um graphical Processing Unit attached
to it so in short these are what
machines that specialize in heavy
graphic rendering and video editing it
also helps with the model training and
interferences with the a standard nd24
RS which has U 448 GB of memory and
2948 GB of temporary storage and the
last but not the least but the best last
but the best is highperformance computer
or Azure H series virtual machines now
they are the latest in uh high
performance Computing VMS and are aimed
to handle workloads like batch
processing analytic molecular modeling
and fluid dynamics lot of complicated
applications in this uh VM and this is
the fastest and Powerful CPU virtual
machine with the optional High
throughput interfaces and the largest
instance size that's available is a
standard L 32s which comes with 224 GB
of memory and 200 GB of SSD temporary
storage and a third common question is
what are the deployment environments
offered by Azure there are two main
deployment environments one is the
staging environment and the other one is
the production environment now in
staging environment let's talk about
staging first so when you're are
deploying a web app or web app on Linux
you can deploy them to a separate slot
instead of the default production slot
when running them in standard preium
premium or isolated app service plan
tiers now the deployment slots are
actually live app with their own host
name and at a later point the staging
environment can be swapped with the
production environment so why do we need
an staging environment what are the
benefit of it so the benefit of
deploying or application to a non
production or staging environment it
provides a platform to validate changes
to our application before it can be made
live in the production environment and
in the staging environment the app can
be identified using the azures global
unique identifier also called as the
guid URL and it's very very similar to
the production URL except that it has an
custom name in front of it that
identifies it as the staging environment
and for production environment uh this
is the live uh production environment
that's serving customers's request
that's serving the customer content now
it can be slightly different from the
staging environment in a way that the
URL that's used to identify the
production environment that's more of an
DNS friendly name like the name of the
actual service. Cloud
app.net that way it differs in case of
staging environment you have an custom
name right before it so the custom name
and then the cloud app.net but in this
case you get the uh direct service name
as the name of the URL so this is live
production environment which receives
and handles and serves customer traffic
another commonly asked question in Azure
is what are the advantages of scaling in
Azure the actual thought behind the
question is to see how much have you
understood scaling how much have you
seen and how much have you applied the
scaling effect in the production
environment and have received benefits
in return so let's talk about it
advantages of scaling in Azure some of
the advantages are we get the maximum
application performance now Autos
scaling is a built-in feature for the
cloud services be it um AWS Azure uh
Google and a couple of other cloud
service providers it's a buil and
feature for a cloud service a cloud
service should be Autos scalable and
that includes mobile services virtual
machines and um when we run our
applications uh on mobile services or
virtual machines the website actually
gets the best performance uh during the
change in the demand again different
applications uh might require different
uh performance needs for example for
some apps the performance measured based
on memory and another good example is
the fluctuating demand for example you
could have a web app that handles
millions of requests during the day and
literally nothing at the night and
autoscaling this environment Autos
scaling any of these environment will
automatically scale or fatten your
environment so to receive the all the
incoming traffic and during lean period
it actually gets Slimmer and Slimmer uh
so to help you with the cost so it
actually maximizes uh the performance
that's what autos scaling does and like
we said Auto scaling scales up and
scales Down based on demand it not only
scales up but also scales down so to
help you with the cost and if you know
the particular pattern in which the
application is going to receive uh
traffic then we can very well go ahead
and schedule scaling to our application
or schedule scaling that infrastructure
based on time if we already know that
Monday to Friday that's the traffic uh
that I would get and it's a constant one
it's not a public facing but you know
it's an internal application so I know
all the 500 users or the Thousand or the
5,000 users who will be using it so at
any given point it's just 5,000 users
it's not going to go beyond that and
during Saturday and Sunday literally
nobody's going to be in office so no
load at all so in that case I pretty
much know how the pattern is going to be
I can go for scheduled scaling if I know
the pattern and autoscaling like I said
not only helps with keeping the
application highly available it also
helps with the cost effectiveness of our
infrastructure so anytime there's a VM
or a group of VMS running on less CPU
autoscaling is going to actually get the
environment Slimmer and Slimmer so we're
not unnecessarily running any resources
and paying for it if you're being
interviewed for the infra site in Azure
this is another common question that
gets asked how are Windows Active
Directory and Azure active uh directory
different let's talk about the Windows
Active Directory first the non-cloud
Windows Active Directory was the service
was released along with Windows 2000
server Edition and this active directory
is essentially a database that helps
organizations to organize the users
organize the computers and a lot more it
provides authentication and
authorization to the applications not
only to the applications but also to
file servers to printers and a lot of
other on premises uh resources that's
what the basic non-cloud active
directory does on the other hand the
Azure active directory is not designed
to manage web-based services the Azure
active directory on the other hand was
designed to support web- Based Services
that use rest API interfaces for office
365 salesforce.com Etc unlike the plain
active directory this uses an completely
different protocol so protocol wise it's
different and the services that it
support is quite different now besides
that it also has couple of other
differences as well and let's look at
them so the actual active directory or
the windows actual directory is a
directory service that facilitates
working with interconnected complex and
different network resources in a very
unified manner on the other hand Azure
active directory is Microsoft's
multi-tenant cloud-based directory and
identity management service and the
Windows Active Directory has five layers
to store data to store user details and
to issue the management certifications
on the other hand Azure active directory
integrates or compresses the five layers
into just two layers here Windows Active
Directory works with on premises servers
like applications file servers and
printers Etc on the other hand Azure
active directory it uh works on web-
Based Services that use restful
interfaces if you're being hired for the
development environment or for the cloud
devops support environment or even for
the production support environment you
might find yourself being asked this
question what are the types of cues
offered by Azure now Azure supports two
types of queue mechanisms the storage
queue and the service bus que Let's Talk
About Storage queue first now the
storage queue which are part of azure
storage infrastructure it provides a
simple rest based uh interface simple
rest based get put and Peak interface it
provides reliable persistent messaging
within and between the services it
follows the pub sub model or a pub sub
messaging infrastructure and it's best
suited for users that need to store more
than 80 GB of messages in the quebe it
can provide uh logs for all the
transactions executed against the users
queue so that's what we get with storage
q and on the other hand service bus cu
the service bus cues are built on top of
broader messaging infrastructure and
they are designed to integrate
applications an applications component
that can span multiple communication
protocols so that way it differs so this
is good for applications and components
that may span multiple communication
protocols calls and even different
totally different network environments
so in short these service buses or the
service bus cues in Azure are part of
azure's messaging infrastructure and
they uh integrate applications or
application components that can actually
span multiple different protocols and
multiple different network environments
it also provides an first and first out
style for delivery and the user's Q size
has to remain under 80 gbit another
familiar question is what are the
advantages of azure resource manager now
the resource manager helps us to manage
uh the usage of the application
resources this question is actually to
test how well have you tested how well
have you used resource manager and have
gotten the benefit of it this question
actually test how easy it has become
after the introduction of resource
manager compared to uh when doing
deployments or when provisioning
resources without the resource manager
so let's get into the answers for the
question what what are the advantages of
azure resource manager the insur
resource manager is called armm so the
armm helps deploy manage and monitor all
the resources for an application a
solution or a group so all the
interconnected application all the
interconnected Services can be monitored
as group using resource manager and uh
users can be granted to access to
resources that they require within a
resource manager so in an account I can
have like 10 different resources created
by resource manager or a resource Group
created by resource managers and I can
allow deny connection to those services
or only to those Services based on
whether the user should be accessing one
and not accessing the other so that way
it becomes easy to give access to a
group of application it helps in getting
U billing details for the group of
resources now which group is using more
which group is using less and which
group has contributed more to this
month's bill stuff like that so those
details can be obtained using Azure
resource manager and provisioning
resources is made much easier uh with
the help of this resource manager
another question is how has integrating
hybrid Cloud been useful for Azure well
with the use of hybrid Cloud we get the
best of both the worlds so what's hybrid
Cloud it's nothing but combining the
public cloud and the private cloud and
allowing data and applications to be
shared uh between them so whenever the
compute or the processing demand
fluctuates hybrid Cloud Compu in gives
businesses the ability to seamlessly
scale their on premises infrastructure
in the public cloud and handle any kind
of uh uh overflow in the requirement or
overflow in handling the application so
it really helps it helps it boost the
productivity of our on premises
application so with the hybrid uh Cloud
we get a greater efficiency with
combination of azure Services uh devops
process and tools for the application
running in on premises and by having an
hybrid Cloud environment users can take
advantage of a constantly updated Azure
service and other AWS Marketplace um
applications for their on premises
environment and the other benefit is uh
with hybrid Cloud environment we can
simply deploy applications regardless of
its locations in case of on premises
we'll have to worry about the location
but when we expand our on premises
environment in the cloud and they can or
we can pick any of the locations and
simply deploy it in them and this
enables the applications to be created
at a greater speed what's federating in
Azure SQL now this question is very
specific about SQL how can we scale the
SQL database now this is a very good
question or a valid question or an
important question in the interview
because many customers or companies have
not been able to meet the user demand
because they could not scale out uh the
databases uh the theory of scaling out
or adding servers to accommodate the
increased workflows and traffic is not
hard to understand but uh the
implications can be very complicated the
implications can be very expensive we
well aware of scaling the web servers
that's very common but how do we scale
the database so Microsoft provides the
tools and Technologies so we can scale
out the database in the cloud and that's
what is called SQL or or Federation in
Azure SQL so the way we scale out the
SQL database is by shorting shorting the
database so Shing actually enables users
to take advantages of the resources in
the cloud not only that it allows users
to have their own database or shared
database amongst each other because we
creating an highly available database
because we having shards in a database
it actually reduces the possibility of a
single point of failure for our database
and more importantly because we're
Shoring uh because we're using
Federation and Azure SQL it provides an
cost effective scaling of our databases
by using Cloud resources or by using
billing only for the cloud resources
that we have used so no pre-provisioning
no over-provisioning it Provisions the
right amount and we pay the right amount
let's talk about this one what are the
different types of storage offered by
Azure now the different types of storage
offered by Azure are as you already know
and as you can see they are Azure blob
storages table storages file storage and
Q storage so let's expand one after the
other now blob storage are nothing but a
massive scalable object storage and
that's very good for storing text and
binary data and asure blob storage is a
a Microsoft's object storage solution
for the cloud blob storage is optimized
for storing massive massive amount of
unstructured data that can be in form of
text or or in form of binary data so in
short blob storage enables users to
store unstructured data and those data
can be in the format of pictures music
video files and lot more and it stores
them along with their metadata and
another advantage or another feature
benefit that we get from blob storage is
when object is changed it is verified to
ensure it is of the latest version
number one and number two it provides
maximum flexibility to optimize the
users storage needs and this
unstructured data is available to
customers through an URL or an rest
based object storage so they are the
benefits that come along with The Blob
storage table storage on the other hand
is an a nosql store for schema Less
storage of secured data now this Azure
table storage is a service that stores U
structured no SQL data in the cloud and
because this table is a schema less it's
very easy to save your data it's very
easy to adapt your uh data as the need
for your application grows and this
table storage is very fast and cost
effective for many type of applications
so some of the some of the type of data
that we can store is U table storage is
good for flexible databases like user
data for web applications address book
storage device information storage and
if you want to store metadata this is a
very good use case to store them in
azure table storage aure files is
another storage uh here it's an managed
file share for cloud or on premises uh
deployment so file storage provides file
sharing capabilities accessible by the
server messaging block protocol and this
can be accessed from the cloud and this
can be accessed from on premises as well
uh here in file storage the data is
protected by SMB uh 3.0 and https uh
protocols and the more important thing
is azure takes care of managing hardware
and the operating system deployments for
Azure file storage so this additional
file storage can be used uh when we want
to burst the storage capacity in on
premises so on premises the primary and
cloud is the secondary or the extended
on premises storage so it actually
improves the on premises performance and
capabilities for our on premises Data
Center and then we have cues Azure cues
it's a messaging store for reliable
messaging between the application
components we spoke a little about this
uh in the previous question so the Azure
Q storage is a service for storing a
large amount of messages that can be
accessed from anywhere in the world via
HTTP or htps uh protocol in here the uh
a single message can be up to 64
kilobits in size and in a queue we can
have millions of messages and the limit
can actually go up if we have not
reached the limit of the storage account
so it's millions and millions of
requests that can be stored in the
storage queue or the queue storage so
the Q storage in short uh provides
message queuing for large workloads and
it enables users to build flexible
applications and separate the functions
one from another so one failing doesn't
affect the other application which is
running healthy and this Q storage it
ensures the application is scalable and
less prone to individual component uh
failures because they are decoupled
separate now it also helps in monitoring
the queue which ensures the customers's
demands are met so Q is a great place to
monitor or a great component to monitor
so we understand how much Peak can be
reached for a particular application
service or a container what is text
analysis API in Azure machine learning
now a text analysis is actually an
cloudbased analytics API and it provides
an advanced natural language processing
over the raw text and it has got four
main functions like the sentiment
analysis or and the keyphrase analysis
language uh deduction and and a few
other things now what do you mean by
sentiment analysis now sentiment
analysis is from the logs from the
commands from the text commments that we
receive do an analysis and find out
whether that positive or an negative
statement now if it is a the API the API
returns and sentiment score between zero
and one and one is positive and zero is
negative and then in text analysis we
have um a key phrase extraction which is
it will automatically extract the key
phrase to uh quickly identify the main
points in that uh key phrase for example
if you're analyzing an text which says
the food was was delicious and there
were wonderful stuff then the API
Returns the main talking points of that
phrase like food food is the main
talking point and wonderful staffs that
was a main talking point so that's
another feature that this uh text
analysis has and then we have language
deduction in text analysis right
irrespective of what you paste it can
try to gauge and try to align it to the
120 or up to 120 languages that it
supports so I can simply take text from
the internet and I can paste it and text
analysis software is going to identify
the language and then can run phrase and
uh sentiment analysis on those text
right so in short text analysis is an
API a set of web services that can be
used for text analysis it can be used to
analyze unstructured statement sentiment
analysis key phrase extraction and lot
more and the results are generally
between Z and one and one being positive
and zero being the negative sentiment
there is no much training or in other
words this is not as complicated as
couple of other text analysis softwares
are available in the market we can
simply paste we can simply upload the
text and we can call the service and it
runs a sentiment analysis on it all by
itself let's look at this question what
are the advantages of azure Q storage if
you're going to work in a development
environment if you're going to work in
an environment that Embraces devop
this could be a question what are the
advantages of azure Q storage now Azure
Q storage is built to flexibly operate
the applications and separate the
functions between the applications that
run large workloads so when we design
applications for scale these
applications can be decoupled so that
they can scale independently you know a
thing happening on an application is not
dependent on another application and
anything anything happens to an section
of the application will not affect the
other application because they are now
decoupled and connected through the Q
storage so the Q storage gives us
asynchronous message queuing for
communication between the applications
irrespective of whether they are running
in the cloud or whether they are running
in desktop or whether they are running
on premises or on mobile devices so in
short this Q storage enables message
queuing for large workloads in a simple
and cost effective and a durable manner
talking about the advantages advantages
is it provides Rich client libraries for
Java Android C++ PHP Ruby and a lot
other services getting added during
every new release from Azure and the
main advantage again is it enables users
to build flexible apps and uh separate
the functions for bigger or greater
durability again introduction of cues
into our application it ensures our
users applications are scalable and less
prone to individual component failures
meaning one component failing is not
going to take the whole application down
right if one component fails it's just
that component that stays fails the rest
are healthy and the rest are going to
function it also helps us to monitor the
cues and ensure the servers areen
overhelmed by sudden traffic burst so
how much do I have in the queue uh kind
of determines the the traffic for my
application and if the Q is more I can
always go and autoscale my environment
and the queue is less I can always go
and Shrink or make my environment
thinner so it can save cost and anytime
there is more data in the queue I can
Auto scale monitor the metric and do
auto scaling based on that metric so the
environment knows that there are more
datas coming in I need to expand myself
to handle that much amount of data this
is a very common question what are the
two two kinds of azure web service roles
now a service Ro is a set of managed and
load balanced virtual machines that work
to perform some task and based on what
it's going to run on top of it is it
going to run web service or is it going
to run worker service defines what kind
of roles that gets attached or that goes
on this virtual machines so we have two
types web roll and worker roles the web
roll is a cloud service role that's
configured to run applications developed
on programming languages Technologies
and majorly they support IAS internet
information service and they support
asp.net PHP uh Windows communication
foundation and so on so that's web roles
and these web roles it automatically
deploys and hosts application through
the users IIs internet information
service on the other hand worker roles
are roles that uh runs applications and
ser service level tasks which generally
do not require IAS so I is actually the
differentiating factor so in worker
roles is is not installed by default the
worker roles are mainly used to perform
supporting background process along with
web roles and do tasks automatically
compressing or uploading the images
running scripts and um or doing some
changes in the database getting new
messages from the Q and processing and
lot more you know the work the
application s are the work that does not
require IAS that's what this worker role
does again the main difference between
the web Ro and the worker Ro is that the
web Ro automatically deploys and hosts
your application through I whereas the
worker Ro does not use is and runs our
application as Standalone this is
another classic question what is azure
service fabric so Azure service fabric
is actually a distributed system
platform that makes it easy to pack
deploy and manage a scalable and
reliable microservices and containers
now service fabric also addresses some
of the significant challenges in
developing and managing Cloud native
applications and the problem that IT
addresses and fixes is now developers
and administators can avoid complex
infrastructure problems and focus on
implementing Mission critical and
demanding workloads that can be scaled
and that can be managed through the
console or from the single place in
short service fabric provides a platform
that makes the process of developing
microservices and managing application
life cycle lot easier and the advantages
of service fabric is that now we can
produce application with faster time to
Market because all the worry about the
infrastructure is taken away from us we
don't have to design an infrastructure
all that we need to worry about is
simply the application and the
application life cycle again the
advantage is it supports U Windows it
supports Linux not only that it supports
servers on premises and in the cloud
with service fabric we can scale up our
environment to even thousand machines in
just a single command or if there is a
immediate need for th000 machines I can
immediately scale them up 2,000 machines
that's possible with service fabric now
let's look at this question you can
expect this question if the customer is
running hybrid environment meaning
having some of the applications in on
premises and running some of the
applications from the cloud and for some
reason when classifying the application
that goes to the cloud and that stays on
premises they have decided to keep the
database inhouse so in that environment
a lot of customers do that so in that
environment this is a classic and a
scenario based question a client wants
the front end of their application to be
hosted on Azure in the cloud and wants
the database to be hosted in on premises
for security reasons or to have full
control on their databases how do we go
about suggesting a solution for this
customer the ideal solution in this
scenario is to use um the v-net based
point to site VPN solution so all the
front end applications will be in the
cloud and they'll be hosted in a vet and
from the vet they'll be connecting to
the database through an point to site
VPN so the traffic and the writings and
the reads are not coming through the
internet but through a point to site VPN
link that's connecting the Azure vet and
the on premises environment and this uh
model or this approach or this solution
is best suited for scenarios where there
are only a limited number of resource
that needs to be connected between on
premises and the cloud this is a very
common question what's aure traffic
manager of course we no more running
applications on a single server we know
more running applications on or or from
a single environment the same
application is being run from multiple
environments within Azure and it can be
running from Azure and on premise as
well so multiple environments between
Azure and on premises and a lot of
customers have such environment and if
you're facing an interview with such
customer this could be an ideal question
what is azure traffic manager now the
Azure traffic manager is a dns-based
traffic load balancer that actually
enables us to distribute traffic between
Services across Azure Global regions and
by doing this it provides a good avail
ility and a good responsiveness to the
application and this traffic manager it
uses DNS to direct client requests to
the most appropriate service endpoint
based on the traffic routing logic and
the health of the endpoints that it
maintains so in short this traffic
manager is a load balancer that enables
users to provide High availability and
responsiveness by Distributing traffic
in an optimal manner across the Azure
when we run the same application in
different regions so some of the
advantages or some of the use cases of
using Azure traffic manager is it
provides multiple automatic failover
options it also helps with reduced
downtime it also helps with the
distribution of user traffic across
multiple locations so one location is
not overloaded and then it helps with
the users knowing from where our
customers are getting connected from
that's another big use case with Azure
traffic manager let's look at this
question right this is an ideal question
now there are group of servers connected
together within an virtual uh Network
and now we need to move them or create a
separation between them how do you go
about achieving it so the question goes
like this you need to isolate Network
traffic among VMS in a subnet which is
part of a virtual network with little
downtime and impact on the user so
that's the given scenario and the best
way we can uh do it is create a new
virtual Network and move move all the
VMS in that subnet to the new virtual
Network now this feature is not possible
with a lot of other cloud service
providers like AWS and a lot of other
providers now in those environments we
might need to shut down we might need to
stop the VM create a new VM based on the
image and it's an Hefty process but here
in Azure I can simply move the VMS from
one subnet to another virtual Network
without needing for any additional
security like the network security group
I can simply isolate them if I need to
by creating a simple new virtual Network
and moving the servers to the new
virtual Network look at this one this is
another common question with respect to
Azure what is public private and hybrid
Cloud so this is really to test how well
have you understood the different Cloud
offerings in the market public private
and hybrid or at least the three basic
and hybrid Cloud now the the public
cloud is the most common way of
deploying Cloud uh Computing
applications and uh it has resources
like servers storage and are owned and
operated by third party cloud service
providers like Microsoft Azure Microsoft
Azure is a very good example of public
Cloud so here every component that the
user is using is running only on Azure
that's public Cloud right let me talk to
you about some of the advantages of
public Cloud some of the advantages is
cost because there's no need to purchase
Hardware or software and we pay only for
the services that we use in public cloud
and there's literally no maintenance
because uh the service provider
maintains the environment for us and uh
with public Cloud we have nearly
unlimited scalability meaning we can get
resources on demand and can meet our
business requirements on demand and the
public clouds are very highly uh
reliable because uh they have a vast
network of servers and they ensure that
uh our application does not fail so
there are some advantages of public
Cloud let's talk about private Cloud now
private Cloud uh consists of computer
resources used extensively by one
business or one organization now this
private Cloud can be physically located
at our organization's on-site data
center or it can be hosted by a
third-party service provider whichever
the case the private cloud services and
infrastructure are always maintained on
a private Network and they maintained on
hardware and software that are dedicated
solely for one organization or solely
for your organization so in short
private cloud in Azure is azure Services
being run within an on premises data
center or on premises Data Center used
by the user to host systems or
applications and some of the advantages
some of the advantages is it gives more
security resources are not shared with
others so higher level of control and
security over our resource and
application is possible and then we have
hybrid Cloud now hybrid cloud is the
best of both worlds so it combines the
features of both public and private
cloud and some of the user components
are being run on Azure and others within
on premises data center so they kind of
share the resources in other words they
kind of share the application half of
the application would be running in un
premises and half of them would be in
the cloud and they will be working in
harmony to support the application and
the business need so that's hybrid Cloud
this is one another good example
question that wants to test how well you
pick services or how well have you
understood Azure products and services
and are picking the right service for
the need so the question would go like
this what kind of storage is best suited
to handle unstructured data there are a
lot of storage options available and the
requirement here is what or which one
would you choose for unstructured data
the answer for that question is blob
storage because blob storage is designed
to support unstructured data it works in
this way it places the data into
different tiers based on how often they
are accessed different tier means
different performance different
performance means different cost
associated with it so a lot of add-on
advantages will we get when we use blob
storage for unstructured data in
addition to it any type of unstructured
data can be stored in Blob store storage
this is not true with couple of other
storage options that we have in Azure
only with blob storage we can uh store
any type of unstructured data and the
data Integrity is maintained every time
an object is changed in the blob storage
and the best part is the blob storage
helps increase applications performance
and reduces the bandwidth consumption
for that application so they are the
benefits that we get for blob storage
and blob storage are the ones that are
well suited for for unstructured data
and that's what your answer should be
it's really an five-step process and if
you have worked and if we have done some
Labs some basic Labs with Azure you can
easily answer this question so it's a
five-step process first step is to log
into the Azure the second one is to
create an uh resource resource or a
resource manager and within the resource
manager you would be selecting the
resource and then pick the uh operating
system do you want windows or Linux and
within Windows what's the flavor you
want or within Linux what's the flavor
you want so decide on it and then U
entering the relevant information
relevant information like the U uh name
of the uh instance or the VM that we're
going to launch and the password uh the
URL that goes with it and couple of
other relevant information that goes
gets itself attached with the VM and
then select the size of the virtual
machine different size different uh
types available for the kind of
application and for the intensity of the
application that will be run running on
top of it so select the virtual select
the size of the virtual machine review
everything whether they're good or not
if there are any changes required go
back and edit them and then come back
and launch and your VM is there for you
to start working within like three or 4
minutes not even 5 minutes within 3 or 4
minutes it gets ready and you can start
working on it so it's a quick and it's a
fstep process and you should be able to
answer it easily if you have done a few
labs in Azure let's now look at some
scenario based question you've been
posted with a scenario so we thought
through it and we picked some common
scenario based question that are being
asked in interview and I thought we'll
present it for you with answers with
explanation so you can get benefited
through it so let's look at this
question you're asked to make sure your
virtual machines are able to communicate
securely with each other to ensure
security or to have good amount of
security what would you do and the
correct and the best best answer for
this would be using virtual Network in
Azure which enables us to communicate
with the internet securely which enables
us to communicate with the on premises
data center in a secure fashion so the
advantage of using virtual uh network is
users can create their own private
Network users can pick their own private
IP ranges users can create their own
subnet users can create their own
routing between those two subnets a lot
more goes into that virtual Network so
it it's very customizable and the users
are provided with an isolated and highly
secure environment for applications it's
completely isolated from other customers
it's completely isolated from other
applications that are running in other
virtual Network that we own So within
our account we can have multiple virtual
networks and one application running on
a virtual machine is completely isolated
from other applications running on other
virtual machines and uh of course all
traffic stays within the Azure Network
Azure virtual machine or within the
Azure Network depending on how you set
up the routing if you have set up a
routing to go or reach the Internet it's
going to go otherwise it's going to stay
within Azure if you have set up routing
to reach on premises then it's going to
go and reach on premises otherwise it's
not going to go and reach on premises
it's going to stay within the Azure and
it also allows users to design their own
network like we already discussed
picking up IPS pick routing you know
picking subnets you know how many
servers should be present in that
particular subnet or how many servers
should that subnet accommodate the size
of the subnet the IP ranges the nting
the masking of ips creating of VPN all
that's possible with the virtual Network
so it really allows users to design
their own network and using virtual
machine is how we secure applications in
the cloud let's look at this other
scenario how do you ensure that that
every time a user logs in they are not
asked to re-enter the password as part
of authentication so you really don't
want your users to re-enter the password
every time they log in to a different
application well all the applications
have their authentication mechanism in
place all of them wants to authenticate
the user before they login ensuring the
user does not log in every time does not
mean that wiping away all the
authentication and authorization that's
present in that application you still
need that in place but how do you make
the user hasslefree so they're not asked
to reenter the password or the same
password again and again let's look at
the options available the first one is
to enable Microsoft account
authentication well it's not going to
fix because with that the user will
still need to reenter the username and
password uh deploy express route uh it's
not going to fix either because express
route is a network level service that
connects on premises to the cloud so
that has got nothing to do with
prompting or not prompting for password
and then we have a setup VPN between on
premises Data Center and Azure set up ad
domain controller in VM and Implement
integrated Windows authentication well
uh you can use the same username and
password for on premises and the cloud
but this setup the the VPN and the ad
controller setup it's not going to stop
you asking for repeative passwords so
this is all about U using the same
password in on premises and in the cloud
and this has got nothing to do with the
not prompting the user to re-enter the
password all right so that's same
password is different from not prompting
the user to re-enter the password they
are two different scenarios so uh that
is also out of the equation and the last
one is configure ad sync to use single
sign on that's the right one so when we
configure the ad to use uh single sign
on then uh it's going it's not going to
ask for the username and password every
time we access an application because we
have logged in and that login is going
to stay active for like 24 hours or so
depending on how you configure it and
within that time you can access a lot of
other applications and it's not going to
ask for the username and password
because you already have a single signed
on and you have signed in using the
right credentials let's look at this one
you need to ensure that virtual machines
remain available while migrating to
Azure what would be the appropriate
service to use right let's look at the
options traffic manager traffic manager
is um is literally an DNS service and
then let's look at the other one update
domains it again has to do with traffic
manager updating the URL so the traffic
manager gets updated and then starts
sending request to that particular uh
URL it's going to take some downtime
because when we update the URL they will
have to be populated to all different
plac places and it takes time so within
that time any user trying to access it's
going to fail and then we have express
route and cloud services express route
could be the in fact it's the right
answer because express route it's an
extension of for on premises and Cloud
environment and in this question it
really comes out from a customer who's
having an hybrid environment so they
have applications running in on premises
they have applications running in the
cloud and they want to have a way to
migrate applications from on premises to
the cloud in other words kind of do a
cut over between on premises and the
cloud and this express route is a
service that connects between on
premises and the cloud uh so when you do
the cut over the traffic is now sent to
the cloud instead of being handled in on
premises in fact the services and the
application is getting down are getting
shut down in on premises so the request
will come in the same pattern instead of
they being handled in on premises they
are now routed to the cloud using
express route and the API calls get
addressed or the the queries gets
answered uh in the cloud through the
express route service look at this
question you are an administrator for a
website called Web game and you required
to validate and deploy changes made to
your website by your development team
with minimum downtime so the real
question is how do you validate the
deployment changes that's made by the
development team let's look at the
options create a new linked resource
create a staging environment for the
site enable remote debugging on the
website and then create a new website
well why would you want to create a new
website just to validate the changes and
doing a remote debugging is not going to
help because debugging only captures
logs of the changes happening it does
not do anything with validating the
changes create a staging environment
could be or is the right answer because
when we have staging environments
anything that we run on production can
be run on staging environment and any
failures that would happen in production
if we simply run it in production can be
captured when we run the application in
the staging environment so that way
staging environment is a very helpful
and useful service and that way I can
catch of any errors in other words I can
validate the changes that were done by
my development team uh before I move it
to production and that reduces the
downtime in the production environment
look at this one last question that we
have for you it's um a standard tier
application is used across the world and
uses Azure website standard tier it uses
large amount of image files so you can
get it this could be an e-commerce
website which has a lot of pictures in
it and this is causing the application
to load slow how can we handle this
situation let's look at the options
given configure blob storage with custom
domain well this application has
pictures but the pictures only the
pictures is not all that the application
has all right so configuring blob
storage might not help this could be an
very interactive website and that can't
be run from blob storage let's look at
the other options configure Azure
website autoscaling to increase
instances at high loads now it's the
picture that's causing issues for the
website it's not the CPU or it's not the
memory unavailable memory not enough
that's causing the application to be
slow so we need to identify what's
causing the application to be slow so
it's not the CPU it's not the memory so
configure Azure for Autos scaling is not
going to help and then what are the
other options let's see configure Azure
CDN to cash all responses from the
application's web endpoint CDN could be
the right answer but look at that it
says uh CDN to cash all responses from
the applications web endpoint CDN is not
designed for that though it can do it
that's not the best way to use CDN to
capture all responses from the
applications web endpoint the proper
design for for CDN would be to Cache the
frequently used ones in other words cach
the static content which are photos
videos logos and pictures and lot more
static content that never changes let's
look at the last option configure Azure
CDN to cash site images and content
stored in Azure blob storage absolutely
correct so here we will have to redesign
the application uh to store the pictures
high quality lazy loading or slow
loading pictures because of the high
quality and the bigger size so store
them in CDN and then the content let it
be stored in Azure blob storage that's
the right way of Designing the
application and if we do it this
application is going to run faster or
the application is going to respond
faster to the users and with that we
have come to the end of this video on
Azure I hope you found it useful and
entertaining please ask any questions
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment box below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upscaling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science CL cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
Channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here